and with that intro music under way I am
now live along with the the living
legend himself mr. grand master mr.
Grand Master not sure if you ever been
called that I'm nervous
master yessir Sarah one is with me here
chess commentator making his first
appearance on chess calm TV yes sir glad
to have you with us are you excited for
the first chess960 Championship on chess
calm yes I am Danny a delight to be with
you and all of the chest comm members
and the twitch TV followers this is
going to be a really an enjoyable way to
spend an evening I hope so and as you
and I get set to do commentary we've
been we've been here together offline or
off-camera if you will and watching all
of these players register we have right
now grandmaster george mayer right there
at the table but what's interesting yeah
29 29 right at chess960 and was laughing
about chess960 though as we've got tons
of super grandmasters who are actually
just not quite as high rated as some of
the more active lower title players
right there's Grandmaster vache legrasse
and the helmet number eight yeah is he
on the break did that happen right arab
falcon eric talkin he is the man from
Dubai right and we got Dimitri and
Reagan yes the young Russian Aparri and
Gregori who just made a big name for
himself in Saudi Arabia and Riyadh where
he made that amazing move Queen B 3
against karyakin
yeah Wow right here we have Sergey
Grigoryants who played in our speed
chess championship he was one of those
who qualified early in 2017 and though
he lost his first round as he he had to
take on one of the top four seeds but
he's a a regular stud here on chess comm
you've got these someone you might
recognize they're from the the
Netherlands Benjamin Bock yes indeed
right as we talk to you and I have been
talking a little bit about your library
and that many of your fellow many
visitors there in Amsterdam come and
rage your amazing chess libraries
embark on on that list he hasn't been my
louts than Daniel Daniel Stellwagen
yawns mates
Erwin lon Erwin me and hinting new one
who are all culprits guilty as charged
they come here I'm in hell person I'm
actually in our home it's three three
floors I I've taken over the top floor
and I'm surrounded by my books and
memorabilia things I haven't given to
the wall chests Hall of Fame I mean to
say and it's just a really really
comfortable environment it's like it
almost feels like every time I walk into
place I'm here to learn well and that's
my attitude today Danny teach me I'm
here though I on that note I wanted to
ask
so you've you've been doing this for a
while and obviously providing chess
commentary you're you know well-known
for the for the broadcast at the Chess
Club and scholastic Center in st. Louis
the Sinquefield cup and as the grand
chester has taken off but even long
before that way before chess960 or
Fischer random as it was called
originally was even really that popular
so maybe I thought if we have a couple
minutes before it starts maybe you could
tell a bit of a story there as far as
how do you how do you have how have you
viewed the evolution of chess960 where
it's come from
you know first kind of being a random
thing I think the amber tournament there
gave it more legitimacy than anything
else four years there in the 90s now
it's evolved where chess960 is is by far
the most popular variant and there's
matches coming up like what we have with
a car Nakamura facing Magnus Carlsen so
how do you view chess960 as a legitimate
and really interesting variant that
people can learn from
well absolutely well first of all Fisher
is kind of wrongly ascribed to the
variant itself I mean pal Benko long
before Fisher so suggested the same and
even way way way before pal Benko there
were other players who had suggested
just such a variant and Fisher random
it's
self was Dean somehow inappropriate and
it became chess960 because although
there are many many more positions in
Fisher random the good folks who looked
at all of those various positions said
we have to narrow it down to 960
positions for this reasons and away he
went and then at one time in Germany
there was a well Fischer 1960 tournament
and it became the place to go and play
the World Championship Peter Svidler and
Levon Aronian were contesting for the
World Championship this XI Anand won
multiple times and it was really really
a great event had lost its sponsor and
things kind of subsided after that I
remember I was playing in the tournament
and Sascha more morisevic man he's
playing in the tournament and I just
played and I didn't like the setup I
hate the setups where the bishops are
all four bishops are in the corner
because what are you gonna do you're
gonna play g3 b3 g 6 b 6 the bishops are
gonna get traded it's it's very hard to
create in balance and so I send they're
complaining and I don't know if he can
set it up but in any case there was a
white King on d1 a white rook on e 1 and
a white rook on c1 and then the other
pieces were kind of random yeah yeah so
I said to Sascha I said hey man what did
you think of that last position he said
I loved it I said you loved it I hated
it
they said what did you do he said well I
castled long on my first move and then
play d4 and e4 and I crushed them in the
center and I thought right ok that's
thinking outside of the box right
castles on their first move right well
that's a phenomenal story because that
exact thing that that that dynamic of
how castling happens in chess960 leads
to some of the most exciting moments in
the speech Chess Championship for us or
any number coveri because you're I think
players forget that they can do it
there's there's all the dynamics of the
king is in the center which leads to you
know crazy types of positions both in
regular chefs in chess960 and then some
of the King goes from b1 to g1 and
everything looks exactly and it changes
everything right so I have set that up
I have set that up yeah and we've got
you know an example of how this might
look with a this is the dream position
you teach the kids right get your right
in the center and crush them with the
pawns up and then I asked Arthur Yusupov
a rival in my junior days we played in
the 77 and 78 World Junior Championships
together and I asked him how he liked
you know Fischer 1960 and he said well
you know it's very strange at the start
of the game in classical chess the
pieces are perfectly placed right the
theory has taken over the professional
game today I mean it's just amazing
right how deep oh I see Geoffrey Jean
has joined theory has taken over and
people like Fischer random because then
they don't have to study up a theory but
what you're doing in Fischer random is
you're trying to rebuild the position
back to a normal right he's a normal
time trying to re rebuild and well yes
on that note yeah yeah as you're saying
that it's speaking of rebuilding we we
are officially underway and it seems
that some of our top seats Jeffrey Zhang
you just highlighted who's rated over
3,000 at chess960 he's one of our more
active strong grandmasters who plays
chess 960 on chess calm but of course we
also talked about York Meier who is at
2,900 we've got to meet your Andre kin
with the white pieces though only coming
in at a measly 2,700 for chess960 yeah
one of the early matchups that has my my
eye
is is this game right here between
Robert has sand and John Barth all these
are two well-known American players and
well-known into the online chef's
community for their commentary and
because of their ratings look at John
coming in at only twenty three hundred
right because of the chess960 rating
they get this early matchup so this
might be a fun one to talk about if you
want we've got this absolutely dynamic
of the bishop on the Queen over here
right by the way it looks to me like
they're playing a different setup then
so all of the setups are different
they're not all the same i I believe no
yes yeah I mean yes game yeah look I
mean it was almost like the commentators
cursed the moment I said my most unhappy
positions are those where the bishops
are in the corners of the start right
that was Geoffrey's position and now
we've got the Queen in the corner over
here so well would you like to look at
should we look at okay you're you're the
host well shows which one they caught
your fancy so I started with this one
here that we're looking at on the
analysis board with with Robert versus
with Robert versus John because I
thought that anytime you get the dynamic
of the one of the things that I hate
most about chess960 is when my queen is
in the corner because I end up spending
most of the time going for the center
and then at some point dynamics happen
in the middle of the board and my queen
is just not where she needs to be to
help but it looks like looks like black
baby is preparing kind of a battery here
to get that Queen and Bishop working
together what do you see when you look
at this position I see white is flopping
all over the place here he's definitely
looks very very uncoordinated that by
the way was a very good move because
Queen Queen h2 the Queen was on it but
the real problem is this you know how
White was going to deal with the center
if he had played 92 there was 96 and the
d4 pawn was pretty tender but this night
on d6 is now being attacked which forces
a very consequential response the knight
was looking really really good
I'm not a big fan of the move but I see
nightie for because I'm not a big fan of
night f7 but see 94 is maybe what Black
has to do here yeah you know what's
interesting is is these died you know
this sort of thing where suddenly one
single move can expose an awkward and
awkward a speck in the position that
just doesn't happen in normal games
right and right and I remember one game
I lost very quickly and there's been
famous instances where super
grandmasters lose in less than ten moves
in chess960 because of this right so so
what what are you this is an interesting
one as they bring up the pieces let's
let's go check on on the jeffrey zhang
one actually because he was a top seed
to start and it's kind of fun to get
different chefs 96 ok this one looks
like was this even chess960 just looks
like black maybe has an edge after
gaining a temple on the Queen is he
about to put that night on d3 ok yeah
Jeffrey's in control here huge this is
actually a Benoni wet dream wipeout if
you will bishop d4 check no this one is
already gone let's go back to that game
of Robert has first that because that
that looked like it was really very
challenging uh-huh
after Bishop f3 were seeing Knight e4
right that was okay that was a that was
a very nice man eclectic to take here
and double the pawns I guess worried
about the germ oil and what that might
be
I was really expecting him to double him
up so to speak right with Bishop takes
f3 because by the way that would have
meant most likely White was castling
long and that was that be interesting
okay now we have a pawn sacrifice
William my spidey sense is tingling here
Bishop takes e4 and what do you got for
the pawn has his pieces seemed to be
coming to life a little bit faster than
Bartholomew's here with the pin the
bishop on f6 you sort of you get this
chess960 flavor a night where it's never
gonna be if you're playing classical
chess a queen where she doesn't belong
although yes there's a purpose in
defending but starting to like Roberts
chances to get the point here
most certainly I'm just I I don't think
95 is a knockout punch but Bishop takes
e4 is certainly a very simple pawn grab
one thing I will highlight as Grand
Master Robert has does well regularly in
our events for all the fans tuning in
and just want you to know I see some of
your great comments coming in and chat
fans I will try to read them soon but
one thing I'll say about Robert is he he
plays high level chess yes sir he's
consistently under time pressure and you
notice even here right he's much better
but he's down a minute on the clock and
when he ends up getting into some of
those tougher matchups later on sort of
foreshadowing where we might go I'm
gonna say that now that Roberts time
management might be a thing that that
comes back to bite him even in a
position like this as you see
Bartholomew Castle and sort of quickly
surprised Robert he's got 49 seconds so
how do you balance that the time being
taken versus the you know that the moves
you got a play on the board Robert seems
to struggle a little bit with that blitz
I think a lot of people struggle with I
mean I work with Viktor Korchnoi and
there was simply no cure and now Robert
a terrible terrible time management h58
looks like it's winning it's just
winning peace looks like an whoa and
there you have it h v so well indeed you
know he's really hassles long was kind
of a kind of a shot of castles right it
we were just talking about the short
game changer in chess960 oh my goodness
you know yeah that was a big shock for
Robert
I think Robert could have simply
captured on a eight captured on a one
and then moved his Queen oh you wouldn't
have been losing a piece that is for
sure
ooh but this is just nothing to be done
you're dropping a piece and Natalie's
scrambling to try to get a second point
d7 and H like both hanging but not
enough calm that clock management really
top professionals in my experience when
you when you think about Levon Aronian
MBL
Magnus mikaru these guys somehow they
just produce a lot of very good moves on
a very consistent easy pace yeah they
get into time trouble but probably bits
because they were losing yeah no I say
that a lot watch the top players played
when they're under time pressure it's
always conducive of the fact that
they're probably at least worse in the
position or or if not much worse right
and and right the top players don't get
under time pressure due to hesitation or
due to bad habits of clock management I
think that robber being the talented guy
he is who you've watched for years and
I've known since he was you know I think
I think that's something that he knows
is is a habit he would like to break but
yes it looks like he's on his way to
losing this one precisely because of
that shout out to some of the the the
match the comments coming in Jay Fisher
81 says I should show you some of my
accents and impressions I tend to claim
to be fluent in crazy accents and maybe
get your feedback on that but we'll save
that for later they wanted they want to
know what you might think of uncle Sasha
but okay uncle selection by the way you
know robert's doing his best he's
rambling he's got it he got to pawn
somehow I don't think that he was
deserving of them after blundering a
piece but he's got two pawns mmm I want
to say fair kicking chances but I'm a
materialist yeah well we've got c5 but
also h4 is hanging right in right but
what are the risk for Bartholomew is is
yeah he doesn't want to really start
trading off all of the pawn for pawn
because that might help that the player
who's down the piece he's gonna try to
make an effort to hold on to keep on but
now now he's got the 93 was Queen g3 was
horrifying I mean I think that was a pre
move he could have played rook e1 as a
prep for g3 now that he's just pitched
his second on that that's pretty much
lights out now yeah he's gonna try to
play some play for some tricks here on
the dark square XI 5 maybe he can yeah
the rook on C one's not not helping the
cause I was gonna say maybe he can
switch to d1 and try to infiltrate gang
up on something but it's really all
outside shots for
four has says as Bartholomew starts to
to put the clamps on the e-file here
exactly you know well dry them back
that's a queen f4 that's the old way
boolean when you're when your material
ahead it still it still the best way in
winning a game are you gotta be a bully
if you have a chance to do it when
you're the one winning there so exactly
this is a nice move here comes Bishop
takes f3 perhaps I'm not sure Roberts
saw that Queen III very nice move sort
of set that up I think yeah yeah
Bart season and and that's gonna
automatic nice well let's pop over to
this York Meyer game because suddenly we
have one were one of the top C's is
still playing and down to eighteen
seconds on the clock okay black has well
I was about to say black had an extra
pawn it could have been sniped that I'm
referring to the pawn on d4 but now with
h4 that's a very very good move
especially in time trouble loosening up
the King I thought the black King was
actually the one under duress
but after this move h4 yeah everybody
why can't take here on h4 cuz it moves
like bishop or check and an immediate
ending on g2 so oh yeah and you got the
touch medium maybe maybe the bishop can
sink itself to e3 it's over you have to
be careful of Queen h5 check here right
so how he goes for that though oh my
gosh are we gonna oh my god yeah no eh
super risky
oh he's f4 came instantly yeah and that
white is white is all the Pinal on the
light squares now ooh you know I keep
wanting to make an illegal move I know
it ashamed that why did he should be 5
check everybody we want the bishop to
come in but the Brooklyn yes we do well
somehow okay is he gonna survive this
these these obstacle positions are so
scary right because at some point the
mating that happens on the color where
your bishop is useless and you know
there's a me and here we go yours
animating that Queen evening maybe as
Queen AJ Queen g7
v8 maybe it's just a draw maybe it's
just a draw I was thinking queen g6 was
mate but there's King e5 oh my okay but
he's still on the prowl and and maybe
Myer might have to settle on that draw
Oh or maybe our national master from
Stan now and me nothing he's though ya
know I thought I thought we g6 was me
too yeah
is he gonna try bishop before and tried
no I don't think Meyer wants to risk it
he's ready to take the repetition as
soon as there it is that that that's
that's four times four times and yeah
they agree Geoffrey did Jeffrey how did
he do what's he got I see got the ring
matter what yeah okay so if we pop over
to our standings here where do we have
right there at the top right now we've
got Jeffrey's young one appointing
grigory one to meet you Andre can one
Arabic Falcon one MV l managed to get
his win salicylate by the way is the
Arabic okay yeah and alright but there's
still there's still gonna be some other
games here so let me let me see what's
going on we've got this game here
between international master Kasparov
who's a Casper off with a see who's kind
of also a well-known chess calm
commodity so let's bring up his game and
see what's going on and this board here
looks like he's got a couple Queens on
the board so that's that's usually a
good sign
yeah yeah one of my favorite things to
have is two queens you know better than
one
and unfortunately for black white
actually even has this very useful beep
on I was about to say he could have
played the move b4 kind of a you know
keeping the perpetual checks
oh no he's escaped up this beep oh he
gave up the people but there should
still be a way to of course just of
course I've seen too many studies though
yeah too many studies where there's an
awkward yeah yes yeah yeah especially
with the King in the corner on a 8 and
you've got Queens on e7 and b7 and
you can't escape a perpetual check yeah
I was just saying that the b-pawn was
adding that extra layer protection if
you will
yeah and you got these weird positions
where the the person with the one queen
is always super worried because you
don't want to touch on a landmine right
as soon as you do right those squares
like f6 where it's a crossfire pin or a
crossfire check just a matter time
before white forces that Queen trade
exactly okay it looks like look at this
white is sort of employed this Queen
energy walking quickie fine over and now
Queen on a eight to do now a very good
either Queen in yeah and now it's uh
it's gonna be all she wrote pretty soon
this is yeah yeah King s7 oh okay making
it super easy on himself here no isn't
it definitely not I'm impressed with
Kasparov ability to play as many checks
as he has without stepping on a landmine
under time pressure but you would think
at some point there's you're gonna run
out of opportunities right interesting
now notice white is sort of slowly
walking the dog if you will walking this
King into the corner where it's gonna be
very hard to play a check without having
a crossfire check against your own King
on each six exactly and that actually is
it right there because there was a
crossfire check oops
no wait if we plan to free trade you
know we will happen if not a resignation
a checkmate very soon so exactly
alright okay and we've seen that MDL I
know it's a very strong field but MDL
one news game he won his game I I don't
think of MDL when I think of chess960
players but you tell me on chess comm is
he you know um he he lost a miniature in
chess960 in one of his in one of his
speech or did he win a miniature I need
I need a uh establish his man his last
speech chess match that he played which
this year he did not make it as far as
he as he wanted to and he was eliminated
by Sasha Crick actually in the second
round yes so but he had a match where
there
some quick 960 losses and I remember
with my cohost feeling afterwards a
little surprised but I I guess I think
of Maxime as a super talented guy right
so I would expect that with with some
experience he should be able to to
perform well in this format we're taking
a quick look of what this game was this
was this was sort of reminiscent of the
one you were talking about beforehand
right with the king in the center and
the so we'll see how the roots yeah how
he approached this okay an early c6 and
b5 very very dynamic very
straightforward yeah he opened up the
position and then maybe prepared to
Castle kingside here it looks like what
he did and then we had a very regular a
very traditional kind of chess set up
here yeah and then he I guess he sort of
outplayed his opponent from there okay
interesting stuff and this so this was
this was MBL's first win I don't think
round two is underway just yet
we have one last game that is still
going so let's let's keep going with
this one yeah and just for everybody's
clarification the round only the new
round starts only when all of the games
are completed that's right and I was
just confirmed by one of our team
members who's watching the show that he
lost in four moves in a chess night four
minutes and it was and it was actually
in the match he won to Geoffrey Zhang
yeah qualified so you what you wonder
sometimes it's that just a little bit of
a lack of focus because he was already
kind of in control of that match or
whatever but but that was that was one
of the most shocking defeats of any of
any speed chess match it was fine if
five moves apparently now I'm being told
so that's cute I mean it's not the
scholars made by the way Queen b3 it was
horrific yeah on two counts because 9a
did it hang the defy pon it hung the e4
pawn as well yeah all right so now the
next round has started and we can choose
our flavor we what would what would we
like we've got Liam Lyon beast here and
the elderly on a fellow grandmaster that
could be an interesting one given that
we were just just sort of talking
about robberies of Lyon b3 I find that
move really a remarkable opening move
what are these guys doing
c4 and c5 okay so if it's a very
interesting approach you and you see it
with these people who these people that
that the people who really like playing
with their Queens yeah right this movie
three early not three wait a queen being
there you know trapped in the corner now
okay I guess MBL when he spiked that
pawn on e5 he thought young my opponent
yesterday he knew okay yeah sir was
commentating and so he said Ron is a
pawn and let's go grab it that's right
yeah but watching yourself in Eric
Hanson yesterday during the blitz match
between Maggie and naka yeah and I think
it was a game that clearly Maggie just
absolutely butchered the oh you mean and
blundered upon but it was like one of
the best Ponzi ever you know thanks to
the open this sword I think we I think
we mentioned you in that game as yeah
I was I was in the chatroom you know
furiously saying that's right take the
pawn okay well here I would be very
prone to playing the move f7 f5
yeah I agree there's a who the
discoverer yeah looking at that Knight
takes F for greedily yeah
by the way I like very much White's
position even after the move that fight
I'm just saying the bishops on h1 and g1
you are actually looking really good yep
place casting on spying their way toward
the Queen sided now blacks uses 19 for
first perhaps with some ideas of playing
f5 later but but now you lose your pot
baby the Queen be the back was somehow
weirdly in some kind of a vortex
yeah you know he couldn't really get out
so okay interesting so okay d4 if I
pardon me threatening the knight on d4 I
think you got to play f6 left or Netflix
or a5 right you got to do something to
get the Queen out of there I wondered if
he could play f6 just from the
perspective that now I I'm thinking
Queen takes d4 is this very nice yeah
and then and then yeah I love that okay
well I think it would've won a piece
oops oh one of the pieces yeah you're
right okay yeah yeah so 96
okay well now White's just White's
grooving and now this is just great it's
an extra pawn and development to boot
Knight B to talk about having your cake
and eating it too I mean you want to put
the knight on c4 I get it but that takes
two moves you know but now that he's
open the e-file he's no longer afraid of
that Knight moving with discoveries as
it's now pin to the rook on the 8th so
why is what is able to keep and guess
what but that's a shot huh maybe it's a
bad one retakes yeah yeah
Queen sex don't have to ask me twice the
white is dual control here this is this
is gonna be a fun and fun and nice
finish I bet yeah especially is that you
realize that the Queen on a a is
virtually entombed it's not checkmate it
but if you think about it how are you
ever going to you go Queen b7 Queen a6
right it's gonna take you know three
four or five moves Jett yeah before you
even anywhere close to civilization
right it's one of those tough situations
when you you've got complete control
right now but your opponent has the
Queen so if you just if you bail on your
pressure and start going after little
things like pawns or such you know then
the Queen eventually gets out and those
those little pawns aren't such a big
deal so you really want to keep why
wants to find a way to keep the heat on
blacks position and not let him exactly
where he's kind of lucky that this
knight on da prevents black from
castling and reaching optimal
coordination right and by the way
nothing very nice move rook e1 stopping
ideas at 97 yeah I should
d five very dominant piece and rookie
one stops that never letting out if 97
can't come in the Queen and what do you
do next
yeah where's she going not a lot of
options here well yeah you had to do
that he had to essentially walk and walk
into that yeah but you know his dream is
to get his night on d8 into something to
play yeah yeah you need play desperately
now this would be a really nice moment
to double rooks on the eighth-ranked so
that yeah he didn't play it I hadn't
expected rookie I was just gonna say
yeah if he had played rook f8 did he
have the time but he has this idea I
just saw every slide position rook takes
e6 very simple way of dealing with it
after taking the rook rook takes c6
Bishop takes e6 is basically unstoppable
threat and and rook takes f6 is
threatened to boot so this is a swell
position that's this will be this will
go down I think is one of our early
favorites maybe one of our team members
will tweet it out but not not every day
you get to see a grandmaster versus
grandmaster queen sac and and going to
be kind of a nice crushing finish like
this but nice game for very crispy rook
a rookie 5 likely and here comes ideas
like 95 in some position or even okay 5
just trap the Queen you know what we say
yeah you know if I was a trainer give me
the towel as you were mentioning my my
fighters taking too many too much
punishment here yeah well here he MBL's
taking his time look at the dominance on
the clock as well really really flexing
his muscles in this one Leone be so
taking his time before he traps the
Queen let's move on to one of the other
top yes let's talk about a Jefferies
game here we've got sure mr. Zhong
taking on another well-known
international master one of our faster
players here this guy has flagged me in
many lost positions so you know if you
get a good position this guy can flag
you despite being down on time here
against Geoffrey is
is captures on f5 on tap takes takes
knight of seven g6 group g7 and black is
fine but okay if I can't take on a fight
then it's time to move the bishop and
just play E for looks like a crushing
position for Geoffrey yeah yeah and this
knight coming into G for doesn't do much
so even a simple Bishop c2 and then e
for is probably good enough yeah maybe
there are some ideas of sacking on f5
and and following it with not even
necessarily g6 but something like Knight
f6 and I have Knight take right he's 7
of o he finds maybe something even
better just puts the knight on f6
immediately yeah Knight f6 Bishop d5
followed by e4 has a lot to be said for
it I must say that looks like you know
ideally placed minors and by the way the
rook on f2 is looking pretty good too
it's all going swimmingly for Geoffrey
here in round 2 now again tell us what
they're playing for Dany yes so in the
overall the overall scheme of things
they're playing for prize money and a
trip actually to the wreck avec Open
where they are hosting a chess960
tournament this year the recognized
Elvin is well known in Iceland as one of
the strongest most popular opens that
people visit every year so I exciting
Stefan and the sponsors of that event
actually reached out to us and and asked
us if we were interested in doing
something that would help promote theirs
and maybe kick off an official annual
chess960 tournament for chess comm
members as well and worked out worked
out nicely so there is prize money on
the line there's also a full full
expenses paid trip to wreck you Vic
Iceland for the Rena copán and then your
pride and actually I'm really glad you
asked because there's a special prize
here which is if you and I decide we see
some favorite games we have three copies
of david Lauda's book the thinker's I
don't know if you've seen that it's got
these amazing photos of players when
they're super super locked into two
chests just thinking and and so we're
giving away three copies of that and
maybe one of them should go to NBL for
that queen sac where were you and I get
to choose them when we want to give away
three bucks for our three favorite game
house we did this well that one for sure
will we will not be on that top of the
list and by the way I just want to say
that I think Jeffrey's technique here
has been atrocious I may be not putting
too fine a touch on it I mean what has
he done
yeah Bishop takes b3 the knight on d4
blocks the rook on the rook on before
turned out I don't know how the rook
ended up on before by the way yeah turns
out to be beautifully placed and you
know maybe white would have trouble even
if the rook on d8 was on d3 but I see
all of Jeffrey's advantages in vibrated
so where did where did it go here after
Knight takes e5 and the pawns falling it
feels like he's still in control maybe
didn't get everything we wanted there on
the King side but where did oh I guess
he blundered this move 93 right here and
yes probably even just putting the
knight on a six to b4 would have kept
White's advantage right back on this
brace Evan
exactly okay so that was a big miss
there and now black is getting better
and that later net worries right
whenever you got a rook and Knight
around a king like this yours yeah
there's a ninety five issue that yeah
you know you can fork the rook in the
pot on g6 so but ya know Geoffrey just
had that I thought he had complete
control and he's really easy you'll feel
bad about his silicon fingers one yeah
yeah I think it's a good idea to maybe
bail out with a pipette yeah it might be
telling he's still got a time advantage
so sometimes in these situations the
competitor gets the best of them right
they just want to flag your opponent but
it looks like he's making the smart
decision I'm saying I really don't have
winning chances here I'm gonna bail out
yeah okay what you ate you had been
mentioning Georgia URI Meier yeah let's
let's go check that out looks like he's
he's still engaged in a in a game here
and and one that is getting he's playing
a colleague from Germany Dmitri
mitri and not only that he's he's
already dropped the draw in the first
round what that perpetual it looks like
he's I don't know that he's in control
of this one either here I mean black
spiders all that upright with the
oscillator on the kingside I mean black
is playing for when you're but maybe
that's a shot he missed right I was a
Wyatt why didn't he just keep rushing
that a point you had eight points the
and by the way black still in control
oh yeah look at this King this is going
to be a domination yeah Kings ready to
make a run up the board and the night
before night c2 and then a1 and yeah
exactly
it's late time like one not York's best
start apparently in just 90 as he drops
a couple games two drops a draw and then
and then a loss and round two de to kick
this one off so well how many games are
still going here hey I just want the
shoutout oh I see Lawrence Trent is also
one of our competitors there to our
audience let us know what you think any
questions I'll do my will we will do our
best to answer them as best we can and
let us know if you're seeing some really
interesting and sharp interesting games
because we've got three prezi's to share
with the competitors as you know we're
only seeing the ones unfortunately with
dozens of games going each round we can
only follow right but if you find a
better Queen sack than MBL's or anything
and aloneness thank you to everybody
who's tuning in right now whether you
are watching us in twitch TV slash chess
chess calm TV all of our Premium Members
all of our twitch subscribers we love
you and we appreciate the love so
alright so this is this winning he's got
he's got a t3 and g3 and g2 coming I
think I think black gets it and guess
what that's unstoppable yeah I'm not
sure
Oh Yin I the young I am from San
Francisco ya Yan Yan Yan Liu you know
yes okay yes I believe I played him
while
ago when he was like nine years old but
I can't remember every game many never
more than me I think we won
Yan and I were partners at some bug
house okay
together so yeah okay new round is
starting new round underway we are
immediately proposed this game here with
Dmitry Andre can the Russian super GM
also with a queen of the quarter we've
seen a lot of Queens in the quarters
apparently that's a random unplanned
theme of the day here we know it's not
immediate Jeep won't push yeah it's like
when the Queen was on a1 you notice the
you know B 3 and B 5 where hot topics
right the queen is like g4 get that
Queen up before it's too late
wonderful names I lost in chess960 in a
rare over the board chess960 term I
think it was a side event in a chess
camp was a position like this where
someone plays g4 and I'm immediately
focused on everything over here and I
think I played some counteracting move
with a dobut of a bishop and I just
blundered upon on b7 and the game's just
exactly right tactic right miss exactly
now I mean it's always been my
philosophy that the opening is just
about the following things your goal is
to control the center full stop that's
the overriding overarching goal you want
effective development for your pieces
you don't want to just put a piece out
there and write and it does nothing so
you want control of the center good
piece development safe king okay and
it's really interesting to me that you
know for chess960
they start with the move g4 which right
as we would know and and chance we
kind of like look at that say dude
you're not right you're not fighting for
the center so I I'm just a little bit
stunned by these very very strong
players I want to emphasize that doing
things that in my view break the rules
g4 f5 what white is doing that oh look
those are rule breakers right not
supposed to be doing this you're wasting
time
you're developing on the flanks and
you're not controlling the center with
these moves and by the way what the heck
was G sex I thought because the guy was
just gonna Castle and play Bishop to d7
and force white to trade essentially on
e6 yeah making GCS 5 kind of a useless
idea I guess and yeah he's creating
opportunities maybe I guess opening the
Queen and and maybe look for tactics on
the Queen side where he's sort of can
spy upon but but yeah I think the other
thing after g6 is maybe if Black gets
one more move maybe he'll maybe he'll
gobble with the Jeep on and trade on the
G the G 1 square yeah I know it's
interesting and that's one of the one of
the hard parts about chess960 right is
you're immediately faced with a setup
that is not it's it's not what you see
in everyday classical chess and so
you're tempted you're you're immediately
faced with temptation right am I am I
gonna try to fix this and regroup and
you know there's a reason why those
principles of control the center exist
it's not just some random rule of GM
back in the day made up right it's your
my niece's are most effective when
they're given their given positions when
they have more options you have more
options when you're in the center of the
board and right and so it's interesting
because if you go away from that you're
trying to play towards the strengths of
this current setup but then maybe you
end up not controlling which is now as
you're as you're saying I agree with you
black seems to be getting more control
over the center maybe although now now I
don't know what's gonna happen of d4 and
e4 strikes who knows right it's not it
looks like tactics are beginning to take
the front seat the moment ago it was
like screeches strategic and stuff right
now tactics because the problem is the
bishop had dropped back to g7 there was
Bishop g3 annoying move just hitting
that pawn on c7 right didn't want to
really play move like Knight a8 but
Bishop d6 is a kind of a concession well
you're dropping the two bishops and I
don't know if that pawn on d6 is any
healthier right good point so he's right
as I was saying maybe black had chances
to get more control of the center
perhaps Bishop e5 was in hindsight
actually just kind
a blunder right he's tempted to sign on
and just misses the D for strike those
surprising moves in chess960 each three
playing playing maybe for a new battery
he doesn't like the Queen he's gonna
play queen h2 and Bishop g3 and as you
said spy that d6 pawn and and that that
actually looks like a lot of dark square
problems for black are on the horizon
without the bishop yes I do like I just
didn't think that h3 was a necessity I
Ellis Lee I'm zealously loved the I love
being on move and I want to make
effective good tempo like moves and are
you telling me that in that position
efore I wasn't in to be played but you
kind of just stop the play h3 okay here
one question even even Bishop g3
immediately first to just ask them
questions how will you deal with this
and then II for as now you've got this
easy so I agree yeah maybe that was a
more like more accurate you know
approach yeah hit the iron when it's hot
here Knight H 93 pardon me I'm looking
at tactics again because you're always I
mean chess960 you're always starting to
look at you know tactics sacrificing
rocks you know Bishop takes d6 he has
played Knight a 7 ooh that looks really
really bad yeah there should be
something happening here is it alive is
it takes c4 person I think takes c4
first followed by E 5 and you know the
kitchen sink is collapsing yeah you can
take with probably the bishop I guess
and then look for I like Rickie Bishop
rather than I like taking with the
bishop and following that with Knight a
oh I like that even better right yeah
yeah X cuz you've got that night on it
okay
right as well as hitting the c4 pawn on
a good day as well ooh CP B here agrees
with NS s is the same yeah this is uh
it's literally a fake safe king right
the Emperor's about to lose his clothes
over there and as soon as that position
opens up it's so we have do we have fake
news and the world is changing yes yes
it has too fast too fast and I'm not
ready for it
look f1 okay a little confounding
because we really thought II five was
just begging to be played Queen g5 stops
Knight a5 ideas you have to go 92 but
now maybe after well I'm not a happy
camper but maybe after d5 I'm still
sitting yeah I mean you open the darks
who are diagonal but at this point it's
nothing to keep this position together
not it's still looking great d5 Knight
f3 you followed by 94 and that's just no
fun yeah that's a square yeah that's a
95 sorry yeah ok this should be 5 a much
better choice defense c4 defends d6
can't ask for too much from a single
move and better still threat alert c4 c3
I was wondering if you might try rook f3
and maybe keep a Brooklyn theidea keep
Larry Christensen paying attention
whenever we get a rook like yeah exactly
maybe okay no he goes 9 definitely with
tempo and by the way there was never a
justification for h3 now's the time
Queen h2 we need you so he's taking his
time here I'll drink it as he really is
I mean it's like he's carefully nursing
every single square or something yep oh
yeah ok he's banking on the dark squares
being more of a long-term problem at
least that's sort of the philosophy I'm
I'm taking taking away from it he's not
looking for the immediate tactics and
thinking I'm gonna get here eventually
and but it you know that that doesn't
seem like the most effective approach
here yeah he's definitely not hitting
the iron while is hot and by the way
that was also instead of the move Bishop
c6 it was even Queen III was a little
odd
concerting yep no I'm looking at just
know what happens when the Queen pops in
e4 is falling Queen d3 check as a threat
and I mean optically just visually it it
looks dangerous and black black
something best to be played right yeah
and by the way a king a one it was
almost our tempo yeah he had kind of
really anticipated that that Queen was
making an unindicted arrival I guess one
of the strange things is Bishop e4 not
possible because of rook e1 that would
be a skewer so that yes black black
really didn't have an effective
follow-up to Queen e3 surprisingly okay
so I can play d5 here or orbit d5 rook
a3 yeah I just get out of my house he
says today yeah well I I never liked
those I don't like my opponents major
pieces hovering around kick them out
kick them out yeah so I like that choice
of rook a3 although I must say I was
also seriously considering your d5 well
now he's infiltrated on the F file as
their hands would say penetration has
started and here come to start in d6
nation and too many things falling here
it's a collapse now Queen tanks d6 is
made
okay well whether it was the most
accurate approach or not patience
apparently paid off
Leo b7 is taking on let's see another
also a fellow grandmaster an aide from
Armenia a weird-looking position that
could have been from a normal chess game
but now has a now has a bishop pair and
a past a pawn and it's all sort of lack
of coordination here on the Kings side
so yeah it looks like the obese is
really just cleaning this one up at this
point yeah they're really it's all about
the past a pawn at this point I mean
there might even be a checkmate with
Queen H 3 and E 6 check you know opening
up the dark square bishop but at this
moment it's you know the the a Ponk is
just marching in
e 2 and a six and move a six just
overwhelming the Queen and Lex says I'll
give up a piece but we're not going to
get more than just a single check to
follow that up nope
here comes probably even just Queenie
six okay he takes here I was wondering
if he would work his Queen back to h3
just to make sure f3 was guarded
she will good I was uh I apparently need
to wake up here so yeah greed is good
oh that Queen I okay okay well lists
this is very simple - that's a night oh
pardon me there's mission from c3 is
still hanging actually kind of
irritating now and Leone beast is maybe
not not blunder but maybe kind of
stumbled into giving his opponent more
chances than he intended this is getting
alone I what was that
there's Queen c4 check and suddenly the
game has yes well unless king g4 sets up
the mating net for whites Queen which
would be yes that's what he's banking on
here he's I'm thinking king of fight oh
sorry I was thinking kina fine
yeah first right now I think you were
right and even now you're right there
were no checks and he yeah yes but there
is a mate there is h8 and g6 well also
invasion is pretty yeah I was gonna say
MPL has had a couple of nice finishes
here today so far I I'm not sure it was
the appropriate way of the game but nice
finish now he's 303 okay on that note I
jumped over to the standings to show our
our members what's uh what's happening
here we still have some not super studly
GM's and right there in the mix you've
got the well-known international master
John Bartholomew but here you see on
Dracon and lyon beast two of the big
super GM names that are right right
there at three out of three we've we've
got Sergey gregorian's as we've said is
a speed chess Challenger mm-hmm okay
Jeffrey Zhang actually
Jeffrey Zhang is not here amongst the
top players at least at this at this
listing here and that's because he
dropped a draw earlier okay
and how is it possible Lauren strength
two and a half out of three I'm shocked
shut the man known as I told him forever
more will be known as the man who lost
upper rook to Magnus and all the know
but Lauren Lawrence plays in a lot of
these events so he's pretty comfy on the
site and I think that open right there
where them is Geoffrey Zhang are our
countrymen today my adopted country man
your countryman Benjamin Bach okay well
who is who's still playing here we've
got one game ooh you know who that is
KMD B that's our boy no I don't
that's the formerly bearded formerly
bearded international master Hamilton
now the shaven soon-to-be Grand Master
among of on the legend fantastic Wow
okay I didn't realize that that I mean
the capital letters they're all kind of
made me think of the Royal Dutch Chess
Federation the K and s B but V B and
threw me off he's no he's always had
that use it I don't even know why I
should ask him what it stands for but
I'm on sporting his new look with blue
hair and a shaved beard not sure if
you've seen that with your conventional
the chest bras but yes so he's he's the
the formerly beardless one actually off
the air before our speed chess match
started yesterday with Magnus Aman was
hanging out in the room with Eric and as
we're getting set for the match and
start kind of chatting and he and Magnus
congratulated him as the formally
formally bearded one so it was a moment
that's great the formerly bearded one
and he's got a winning king and punning
game king of e5 double x clan and King
a4 figured it out only moves yeah and
then King B for very important
apparently can be P is a Dutch song the
team we're actually being told in the
chess TV chat right now so that's a ah
that's a good fact there you have
it and now we know that when the king is
on
III Tempe yeah it's over it's winning
king yep and b3 b2 b1 it's a girl daddy
it's a girl everybody's excited the
family rejoices firstborn daughter yeah
that's a that's a fun clippable moment
we've got we're getting a lot of
interesting comments in the chat one fan
log Logan Chan seller said made a
speculation that it would take alpha
zero minutes to learn chess960 rush all
of these grandmasters what because we're
starting a new round and you know some
openings are get going before the
exciting moments give us give us
Grandmaster Sara Juan's thirty second
assessment of all the Alpha zero drama
and what that meant for chess and and
all those high heels I absolutely
absolutely loved it and I love the game
and I thought it was just fantastic
and here's one of those moments where
black blunders upon because of the
immediately oh no it's apparently it's a
control no you could have taken the rook
taking the rook and taking the pawn with
check you could have picked up the c7
pawn with a check yeah white just
blunder that takes yeah thanks Jase oh
yeah you know you don't get to go Bishop
takes e2 yeah and look and that's Sergei
Grigoryants I mean that's a that's a
very strong grandmaster taking on his
fellow Russian so that said that's a big
miss there you're right by Gregorius oh
the all-russian matchup yeah okay c3
again it's this you it's this amazing
tempo a waste it didn't move the c3 in
my opinion as a move you can always play
you're not a hundred percent sure you
want your pawn on c3 but you're pretty
sure you want your knight on f1 to go
somewhere Knights on F water are not not
that happy here ya know so you go D 392
and you Castle and get on with the
business okay but having said all of
this this looks incredibly even-steven I
mean check this out Bishop's of opposite
color
and an absolutely symmetrical structure
yeah yeah you've got both bishops sort
of biting on granite over here on d5 and
d4 not not much to it especially because
the F oh look at that Wow
creature okay let's see that will not
win one of our books not with one of our
books that all-russian match up there
was I mean I daresay prearranged but
definitely peaceful I mean those guys
were just like well this isn't let's not
beat each other up here interesting okay
let's go to Jeffrey and Lawrence
oh god that should be fun yeah I agree I
like that Justin and here whoa okay
somebody seven is a problem something
crazy has happened when you see a bishop
on f7 like that normally it's not
checkmating the Queen I've never seen a
bishop on f7 that I liked so this is a
problem for Lawrence and now here comes
nine f7 with devastating consequences
just reminds me of a game I lost quickly
in chess960 to Simon Williams I tend to
remember how quickly I lose a lot I
don't know and maybe I need to work on
that I don't know but here we go this is
a 96 Geoffrey is just cleaning up right
okay how about yeah this is a cleaner
how about MV oh yeah let's do that so
we've got Leo beast here with the black
pieces only on a username that I rarely
do not rarely do I not recognize who
they are I don't know who that is so and
it's from Tajikistan that's a very yours
that is not a hobby of yours your flag
knowledge you have no mind-blowing right
it's probably due to many Olympiads that
must be it and what do we have we we
definitely don't have a castle King and
remember our guidelines in the opening
what is it that we want because they
want to control the center good squares
for our pieces King safety white has
failed on guideline number three yes and
a sight line number two as well I wonder
what okay so the one V White has going
for
is the long-term idea that maybe the
light squares because black lacks the
bishop pair could become an issue but
other than that long-term feature I'm
looking at 96 Knight c4 for Maxie very
bigoted I'm looking at maybe do I
challenge the sefa okay he brings the
other night in to d6 perhaps even better
right this Knight is already sort of
well placed where he is so I I actually
thought he was gonna go Knight d6 and
Knight a5 and Knight c4 but okay it's
actually just the very very same tempo
right Tempe so and you know you always
look how you're going to do with the
knight coming to f7 I don't think it's
on the cards but maybe he's giving you
always want the extra option right maybe
he's giving himself the option of g5
highly unlikely but he's gonna get a
Knight to c4 and then there might be a
very promising tactic against the e3
policy one of the games that I'm not
sure if you caught yesterday where
Magnus slowly relocated to Knights in a
queen to eventually have a devastating
stack against Hikaru yes I did I was
around for that one yeah so okay so if
you please notice this is a feed a
master and a tough matchup taking on one
of the world's strongest chess players
and maybe a future a future candidate
not this year because of the candidates
system but maybe somebody will see
eventually challenge the throne but okay
this is just getting a really tough for
me I remember the first time I met MDL
maxeen in vikon's a huh and he was
having a post-mortem we were just
analyzing and I made some suggestions
and I tried to him and I said Maxine
your English is excellent he said oh my
god you can never say this to a
Frenchman seem and I were talking before
the event today Maxime is is actually
gonna start his own twitch channel very
soon everyone everyone wants to get in
on the on the chest bra action there and
build themselves right
twitch twitch chess streaming channels
so fans for that now now that he's come
as far as he has in terms of our team
training him I feel safe letting the cat
on the back cat out of the bag that soon
Maxine Boucher magrav will be streaming
chess regularly so look for that how
exciting
oh my goodness and with this I'm gonna
get myself one of those big huge monster
screen you know televisions smart things
whatever yeah and I'm just fearful like
I'm just gonna be a couch potato for
like the next 20 years quite some
theater and with you know all of these
as you were saying streaming oh man I
mean what a future to watch in life
right and these we don't even have to
schedule we can binge it's just you know
we're we're too spoiled in terms of
content but totally back to coalition so
we have that I don't see for here comes
II for what it's it feels like it's
taken a little bit of time for Maxime to
get out from coordination but at some
point are we gonna see an e5 strike and
just let everybody come to life or is
that too much good luck I'm not even
sure you have to it probably probably
because II 5 you know with a knight
takes e3 but but the problem is is that
these Knights are so good right what
white doesn't really want to trade them
but if you play for example Bishop d6
and f5 and rook c8 it's just sort of
like you know do you really own the
position it just sits on the position
and you know all that note I actually
really like everyone I think I think you
should have played Bishop d6 cuz that
would have maybe kept this night here if
this Knight came in right maybe then he
could have just sat on the position and
was review today yeah yeah but okay this
again shows this move e5 very much like
the b4 move we saw when his when MBA was
white he is a player and it's just the
nature of the game today of the top
players they do not sit idly by right
they are looking for activity and
dynamic forcing operate you know play at
every opportunity and here we're seeing
just that I mean MBL it spied an
opportunity to sit on the f3 Square
Union he just went for it right now I
think on an alpha zero level that
initial suggestion bye-bye you Bishop d6
maybe grinding out some of the
advantages that already exist who we
just blundered the clean clipper board
does the Queen yeah Danny tries to say
something that doesn't matter and
somebody blunders story of my life right
there so the right way no as you were
you about to point out that and before
you do that
Knight H for the Queen was trapped but
wrongly if ya you can't play Queen G for
cousin Queen F to Queen g'wan walks into
Queen f3 which is even really since it's
scorching that would have been a fun
yeah so actually it was it was just over
blunder or not right exactly we we tend
to make more blunders when we're already
in bad positions whether we realize it
during the game or not afterwards we
look at and be like oh i blundered
because i was already completely worse i
I do that a lot right yeah all right so
well as we have here we've got how about
a mana and a Salim I was just gonna say
that he looks like he's Lamont is
literally living off the increment right
now and sure is he's a pond down and he
it doesn't look good yeah it looks like
the Arabic Falcon Grandmaster Salim is
is on his way to victory victory ooh
very strange move that c4 I thought that
the simplest way by the way was roopd 6
followed by f4 okay yeah just use your
majority here on the kingside makes
sense
well because then if you take twice oh
well it's doing you would have had too
many passed pawns yeah yeah still going
nicely Selim looks really really good
here probably here comes out for what
the doctor oh there's well yeah yeah
everybody there was a shot there with
Knight c3 for King the king and rook
so exactly and here I think it's time
for Knight f2 its centralized the night
Knights belong on central squares I
can't emphasize the
bringing us back to like good
old-fashioned chess education I love
this man and was basic right yeah yeah
and look at that
Oh two connected passwords two is better
than one especially when it comes to
pass pawns but now what has he done what
he blundered rook-a for he had to keep
the work on their third Greek exactly oh
my he wanted to keep an eye on the a
pawn everybody and missed that might be
the draw right there I mean honest
that's a sneaky check though Oh Aman
Aman with a sneaky I think he's got this
move coming he wants King see for me oh
no nice okay nice III also guards the
pawn and creates maybe a net right well
yeah I think they would hear it here
comes yogi five amazing oh my goodness
is on his way to swindle Inge his way to
a victory here nice e5 checkol no no I
draw okay
no no no it's King c4 whoa wonder he
blunder with nine at four oh no it's all
over it's all over
oh my god I was what a turn I mean that
game was going back and forth there was
no reason to have any analysis there
because we were the moment we tried to
say something a blunder happened on the
board so exactly Wow my okay my work
well where does that put us in terms of
our standings let's let's pop back over
here and see by the way I think we have
still a game between gear okay you're my
anchor okay growl look at the standings
in just a sec oh right that's one oh
that looks we can see this is what a
royal fork they're the best those are my
favorite yeah well look at that you've
got John Bartholomew performing at a
high level here one of the last non or
grand master titles
we've also got this video master J s
Martinez I do not know who that is maybe
one of our living us who is is 3045
rating by the way huh my goodness
absolutely absolutely playing like a
monster here so no okay well one of the
other Jegs still annoying um good
question
oh it's that tired friend Robert heck
yeah yeah Robert has there yes yeah it
is unfortunately looks to be in a you
know okay maybe a drawing spot maybe a
drawing spot here actually black has to
be a little careful now that that epon
is passed you don't want to tree
yes exactly yeah it is in the worst
possible way so it's time for I don't
know Queen before check and an e4 yeah
so he's I think White's okay he's doing
just fine now
Queen to d4 begging for oh we've got a
loud King D 3 or King III I think he
could have just put ooh
is there a main chat Queen check no mate
white runs out of checks and may still
be an in drawing potential yeah very
much so I think with the King so far
Bernie the black King Jeff are away and
now here probably kind of onslaught of
checks that black guys just be careful
right if you trade Queens is there an
opportunity that White's King just runs
up right and winds of exactly surprising
King and pawn ending victory
speaking of means that remind us of
yesterday's magnus carlsen merciless
take our nakamura match right there was
that in game the hikaru really miss
played right and eventually lost in a
similar fashion of a queen ending i must
say unfortunately for hikaru yesterday
is probably one of his worst game is
ending was just like a just and he's a
very very good end game player I mean
he's won some wonderful games but
yesterday it was like you just it looked
terrible evike he couldn't play an end
game yeah okay so that was a draw that
was a draw so our land master in action
is over here Oh a knight and Bishop me
this is always fun too small
yes and an easy za he's turning on the
the forest made in 1917 if those of you
who don't know the theory maybe we'll
have time to quickly back up and show
you but this right here this is the
problem or the the puzzle book pattern
where white puts on the on the thrusters
and then I every move here is just
well-known theory in black black has
just made it by force right night night
b7 was actually the the normal way to
come there exactly
actually now he's now he's kind of
managing with the six by the way who is
also the animal way to get there you
want to put your King on b6 just put it
on this is back up yet so normally right
here everybody you have the the pattern
that continues when the bishop continues
mmm yeah you walk the king over and now
we've just that's ready
the well you can take away two square
make a make a wasted move it doesn't
really matter there's a million ways to
do it but this pattern is super super
important to remember everyone because
you have a position where it first seems
counterintuitive because you look at all
this space and you say how can I stop
them from getting out right and if you
don't know that there's this trap that
exists where at the last second the
bishop and Knight will work together
perfectly to control every square and
reclose the box so fun the night is
beautiful beautiful invisible wall right
you know you just keep keep blacks King
me there but guys for me the dough that
the one thing I always said is Bishop
versus night you have to make the guy's
King on the color of your Bishop in the
corner yeah so that's the the most
important thing for you to remember I
mean it's actually quite an easy win but
you just got to drive your opponent's
king to the to the corner of your bishop
by the way it looks like a kind of a
Scandinavian there you see a n you know
and the owl the big act he loves his
activity and and we like that he's
playing for the center-right he's
playing chess yes want it to be played
let's open lines in the center and then
coordinate are a misplaced chess960
pieces to get back to chess principles
and and we've got this is a big I think
we just stay right here what do you say
I think yeah you need to be right and be
overseas on drinkin I'm being that did
that these are the big names the big
names by the way I got a chance to meet
Dmitry and person I played a lot a lot
of blitz with him over the years and
really yeah online Amin and finally to
meet him in person he had come with his
wife and daughter to vikon's a last year
so we got to hang out and a really
charming charming couple
but his daughter like stole my heart
I need especially when we visit the
museum together 96 I know it's not a
caro-kann and you know but it definitely
has that you know yeah I should pond e6
you know Queen on c7 you know that
really solid you know Fort Knox
variation and the kirpa karo but I like
what I do I like blacks position here
spite his double pawns these double
pawns are so useful right there holding
back the 85 and they're controlling
these critical squares absolutely and
Bishop eat and black is doing a
fantastic job at completing his
development Bishop e7 castles long a
castle short right I mean to say it's a
long play the kind of the prophylaxis a6
and you know stop this and then maybe
take his time if he decides he actually
I don't know where he's gonna want his
King but yeah either way if he he ends
up going for h6 I guess just to kind of
put the kibosh on that a pawn march but
but I agree I like I like MBL's activity
here right it is very in a very short
period of time especially after Bishop
e7 and castles Knight f4 and queen g4 is
gonna cause white a serious accident g3
not so much as I want to play Bishop
cheat whoa rook e8 he the MBL saying I'm
gonna castle long and I know
and and very quickly well that was one
of my selfish ideas I was embarrassed to
say it because I realized I think your
kingside castle's was much better but
and bl deciding to go back to that I
guess the point is the e-file isn't
owned by any other rook so why not do
that and now I'll get both my rooks
immediately on these two open files and
he he knows just that before we can
finish saying it yeah and there you go I
mean basically black has done a great
job at bringing his Peter bishop
especially on c6 very effective the
Queen 97 rook on d8
we're gonna I ate three there for prime
me very effective pieces nighttime g6
looking for greener greener pastures
1975 is a kind of an automatic currently
sort of staring at squares that every
Russian schoolboy knows why this night
on Jesus isn't good right you don't put
Knights and I one of your G or be pawns
right and well the bishop on f8 actually
is actually terrific yeah you don't need
to move it I mean it's it's it's just
very nice
I've King b8 okay that goes against the
grain I would have lost money knowing
how actively
mvl has been playing yeah betting on I
would have expected him to play tonight
east 7 right away you know I'll attempt
oh I mean not even to consider anything
else
so King b8 that's a safety first move
well here he goes with Knight to d5
maybe well though now he's maybe gonna
be a little worried that if Knight d5
Bishop e2 if you don't have a follow up
you might have to deal with c4 next so
he decides to put this right the knight
on f5 instead but but you've made a
great observation this is like a good
Carroll con a good Scandinavian for
black right yes everything about blacks
pieces is the dream that you hope to
achieve in those positions and full stop
nothing else to say and by the way
Knight takes d4 being a major threat
Bishop takes f5 town takes a fight would
have been just gross two bishops and
black as is is really all over white f2
is hanging
lots of bad things happening but Knight
of three I don't think that's really a
cure either
whoa timeout there what the heck was
that wasn't wasn't Bishop f3 and I was
he was he worried about an inner miss Oh
is there Bishop f5 somehow a big tree
no no no Queen f5 sorry so you're
jealous you just taken with a piece yeah
yeah so you have to take the the bishop
on f3 Knight would take on d4 and well
that looks the bishop is about to come
to e5 yeah yeah I agree a surprising
choice by the way the current position
is exactly that one where Bishop takes
f5 could have been played a moment ago
that White was trying to avoid
so MBL has actually got white to give up
at lathe for a minute yeah yeah oh
that's a nasty move g6 that's just like
don't dare you're gonna do it though
you're gonna find out what the
initiative can do when you're Queens on
h7 right that's what every Hill is about
to do exactly well as my longtime
trainer Nick alignment never would say
why it's going to die with a full tummy
Mike's gonna die with a full tummy which
you know I guess there are worse ways to
go you could argue Robert oh five eight
five says why is it every Russian
schoolboy and not just every Russian
knows chess is so big in Russia he
doesn't have seen the schoolboy
reference well the the school I mean the
BOD vinick's school of chess the russian
school of chess was literally
established in so many russian school
boys that went through that i guess and
also there was the coined phrase that
developed by guys like your molinsky
saying the russian schoolboy but maybe
yeah as you have a comment on that is I
think saying Russian schoolboy is the
appropriate reference to every Russian
schoolboy knows but never wrong that's
when that's why I've always heard it
myself yeah I mean you know there you go
not sure why if that bothers you Robert
but I'm pretty sure that it's a it's a
reference to the Russian school of chess
and every you know they teach chess in
regular schools or you know I don't know
but I you know I think it's appropriate
all right what's going I think MBL is
about to show us the initiative and
and all the magical capabilities that it
has this is this is gonna be it's gonna
get run here yeah they should be four it
says right it's almost lights out it's
like this like all kinds of day you
don't like right scary movie six or
something
somebody's gonna be holding uh-oh I'm
asking finish yeah he's not even if he
takes you don't have to take it to you
have Queenie four check King c1 and then
Bishop a three followed by made on c2 if
you want by the way there you have it
yeah spike check we we left with a spike
check we love that's what that's one
thing that stock fish and other
computers teach us always give the spy
check before you always yes yes well
that was impressive honestly with the
black pieces in a chess960 game MVL just
showed his class there and took down one
of the other top players in the event
without question on the other hand
Dimitri just boy I don't know what
happened to and you know sometimes
people are unrecognizable right I mean
you see a kappa blanka loss and you say
who was that guy - the players nobody
would have known right well right but
that was um I have not seen I mean we
all have now got bad moments but that
look really gross I mean Dimitri is not
supposed to go down like that
what else he got for his day I just
popped over to the standings view to
check out who was leading after Leo be
so gets that big win versus fellow cm
and fins Oh 905 we have I M versus FM
action interesting right there really up
of the standings and we've got we've got
this game here between international
master bartholomew versus our feed a our
our mysterious feed a master martinez
still wondering who that is but let's
let's take a look at it well at the
moment I must say that I always liked
the hedgehog positions as black I had
this favor favorable impression of them
and I like blacks position before this
move kini 7 I don't know what that was
kind of like the King on e7 actually bad
d7 but I like I like the extra center
pawns for
I think that the game is pretty even but
I just like black structure a little bit
more yeah I agree
time pressure is is probably going to be
part of what happens in this game right
the result may be decided by by who
manages the clock better hear both sides
getting a little bit back with the
increment but still under 20 seconds
here for black and yeah okay
so after wasting a few Tempe with this
King the King has actually come back to
the c7 the Queen site this night on a5
just kind of an alert you know that
night may not return oh that was a
strange move for me I was expecting the
night to go to d7 the night on earth
correct before yeah careful I was gonna
say if you move that rook you have to be
careful of shots on d6 and okay maybe
not right away but look here comes f5
perhaps or you started looking at all
these tactics with absolutely hanging up
together on this square on d6 and you
wonder if soo
he missed Knight takes e4 though no way
cuz he's got 93 check coming
maybe Oh big time all three seconds Wow
what a heartbreaking loss there for
Finn's jeaious Martinez have been told
is Martinez Alcantara Jose Eduardo
a 2500 feet a master so a a talent just
like that and whites right back in the
King Schuster goblet here he comes upon
is a pawn is tasty oh my goodness what a
oh you almost had to set that up
perfectly yeah it was mutuality wonders
and a7 has also been been tossed away I
thought that black was going to get in
an ace
six you have to maintain an extra pond
over there but now it's all white white
sand cruise mode here
absolutely yeah this is uh and pardon me
who is white again we'd almost lightness
John Bartholomew John again sir
International Master John Bartholomew
from yeah yeah okay King e - oops
yeah you got he he gave a gift and then
he got a gift right back and and that's
that's why he ever yeah that's why the
game has played though as they say right
is that science blunders blunders are
made by human beings so that's right oh
no no this rookie and black get made in
here in a second if he's not careful
true that King c3 and white is cruising
with f7 Wow Wow
that looks like it's over King b3 don't
even allow a 93 check yeah that was the
safe square to go to the game will come
she's a girl and she's a girl family is
happy and wow so that was a WoW so what
just happened there let's go back over
nightstand I think I think we have two
perfect scores by the way yeah 22 we've
got an obvious matchup in the next round
with with John and and Bo
yeah man you talk about time trouble
[Music]
being the decisive factor and yes one
well our feet a master drops there but
still obviously a talented guy right
there amongst the top of the standings
as we can see we were just reminded by
our own Peter daughers that Maxine Bosh
Shayla Groff is actually not in the
candidates despite to the heartbreak of
Frenchmen across the planet but that
means he actually could play in rec avec
and he might play in Reykjavik so this
this this tournament I mean I'm sure MDL
can get into a lot of tournaments but
this is this is a fun one to play in for
him
who knows maybe he's added Iceland to
the schedule so whatever mind everybody
who's tuning in thank you for being here
this is the first ever chess comm 960
Chess Championship flying alongside me
here is the one and only grand
master yes or sara one pleasured the
baby we're only halfway through thanks
to all of our subscribers and our
premium members please consider giving
us your support there and we appreciate
all the love what do we got here we got
okay
Brooks in the corner I think I think
probably we need to follow the game
between between dalam you and and Lyon
beats just because this is two players
we've been following from the start and
two of the leaders in the event now wow
look at this
g3 and Queen h3 yeah and what do chest
coaches chess classics coaches preach we
don't develop York wiener early yeah
first two moves people he rebels got his
eye on d7 he wants to make Bartholomew
before move ten apparently he's gonna
play nice c5 and yeah so no beautiful
smothered mate you bet
although once again and kind of like
well the night on d3 can be supported
with F 495 so yeah maybe maybe maybe
it's okay but it looks no I I was gonna
say there's anything I think you were
which whenever the Knights in the center
blocking your own pawns right it just
it's you know you're not to the
principles of chess and it's gonna lead
to some space problems but okay if yeah
I agree if he gets f4 and e4 he can kind
of justify the Knights in their current
position here agreed agreed big time to
by the way because if you do get F for
an e5 in you get those doggies moving f4
is just it's a screaming move to be
played
you play e5 and you'll kill that Bishop
on h8 that would be very juicy for MDL
for white castles lul out he's giving
him as opportunity to get an e5 yeah I
think it feels gonna gonna take that
opportunity right why not is there
something he's nervous about maybe he's
thinking about castling along himself
okay what's the rook they're committing
to the fact that he plans to castle long
at some point yep exactly what it does
maybe he just didn't like Knight f5 I
guess as a response
wants to keep the keep the lines at bay
controlling these squares for now
fair enough guess I think that that's a
good one because like you say after he
595 yeah there's always been annoying
undermining f6 g5 maybe he just felt
like he could restrain himself got it
okay so b3 okay that was a question I
was going to ask now after night a3 um
you're not castling long or are you yeah
I guess you can't be I mean they made uh
nathan is yeah yeah no no legally you're
fine but i'm i guess the night on its
own isn't doing much but there is this
night de Flore yeah and II really like
Steel's approaching out of the e5 move
you've been pushing for because now that
there's no 9f5 this move makes so much
sense you might even see the e4 square
used by a number of look even the bishop
to recreate a battery I think there's a
lot of opportunities coming to that
square by the way I think that would be
one of the funniest overs I've ever seen
yeah rookie looking forward to rook a4
to trap the knight on a three it's like
what oh that's a pawn Knight takes d5
yeah I like it
anybody ship takes I guess the same same
pretty good yeah I think I think that's
just a stone-cold blunder yeah it looks
like it must mean because by the way
King b8 was a move that you wanted
anyway in the guards the bishop right it
just yeah totally right so you know defy
yet well who puts their queen on h3 i
mean my god by the way queens coming
back to GT comes i dozen cruise control
now Queen sheets you will come with
deadly purpose yep she's powerful she's
gonna she's gonna use her powers now c2
is under fire but I think rookie for
Queenie for you'd love to actually find
a way to use the be four square where
the night
to enter into one of these happy homes
but you can't write as this is the issue
so maybe MBL's gonna calculate something
yeah this night moves to the wrong
square maybe this move wins on the spot
huh something like those commentators
curse I was just about to say I really
like rookie for you you didn't that time
I use I stick my foot in my mouth and
then have to take it out you never
didn't quite get there so don't worry
yeah ouch yeah but Queenie four okay
you're pointing out one of the things
that white has on in his quiver their
night before if they but this night is
gonna have to go from c3
how about night be one with the idea
Knight takes b1 Bishop takes d4 and
somehow the ponies track I don't know
you may not be a happy camper
you know night 84 isn't completely oh
you like your again yeah there's
something about it yeah no I agree
now after cakes see black would love to
bring the Queen to a3 to help but your
one move too slow and if you have to
commit back maybe even c4 and and this
night moon is officially running out of
squares so yeah yeah we might be
predicting looki the line either way by
the way Knight b5 isn't the end there's
no further move so for example as you
add NC 4 nicely
yeah you're not you're not you're not
galloping away to greener pastures
c4 still on tap but by the way Queen a4
is a deadly threat yeah that's the
deadly threat right now right oh sorry
you mentioned the deadly for that I
apologize 94 have you mentioned that
yeah you mention that it's time ago
night before and it's they're all gonna
shake right there no right before is the
handshake yeah I think I think it's and
be able find it he does and we are back
to an idea that didn't work a dozen
moves ago but fans that's why you want
to always be aware of these ideas
because once you recognize them may
something changes and later on it comes
back as a possibility so it happens in a
universally every game I plan on looking
at a line of sacrifice that doesn't work
in a particular position but thanks to
the pond trade that that uh the
sacrifice my works but that was a nice
game and they all look good I mean I
know honey but that but then again his
d5 that was out that was a terrible one
yeah it just blundered his way into a
into a loss thereby it was one of those
pawn blunders where of course you regret
losing the pawn because you just missed
that the Queen was pitting e6 right but
then the whole position collapses from
there right without that prior to light
squares we're falling apart and and so
bad bad luck so to speak but also just
yet happens when you make blunders at
eye level but by the way that that way
you know funnily enough Magnus was
blundering pawns yesterday yep
but he wasn't blundering like those
decisive ponds blundering 1/8 I thought
that d5 pawn that was more than just a
pawn that was that was a very important
central and there you have it 6 from 6 +
MV ow running away from a very strong
field whose whose in the case I was just
bringing that up for the fans to see
looks like not only is he running away
with you but he's the first to finish
there amongst the top right 6 out of yes
and hole we have our our choice here
let's let's see so with the young men Oh
Oh car heron Tory right here yes and
he's also taken on another young man but
I guess not quite as young but a
countrymen there from Russia so what do
we what do we see about this position
hmm well we've got a couple of extra
pounds for black a good sign for him and
well I I mean it but black would just
actually just be overwhelming the
winning if he can manage to put his
dark square bishop on the long diagonal
that's the maneuver he wants but and
he's willing to sacrifice in exchange do
it
did he just bishop takes a 300 the
follow-up Bishop a4 sweet yeah this is
becoming and what's he gonna play on
Queen before though what's the well I
want to see the knockout but I don't see
it
yeah well it's time to give a check I
think on d8 if I'm yeah check if King a7
we have 95 and if King B says maybe
there's a diagonal problem right right
okay so I guess that that looks like a
Knightley's rook c8 is the sbox
what's funny thing it says Bishop on e3
is trapped right so after trade on C's
is a move like Queen c2 possible and
just that's what I've been thinking
about maybe go yeah d3 Black's calm
because you had so many pawns to start
this with by three if you go for this
there's no immediate win for black but
it's but the King is open and there's a
whole lot of weird pawn things going on
here well I'm
yeah well he's going for it I'm I was
thinking Knight a - okay yeah even
better you
yeah well King b1 you know I rise this
idea was how you can get opened up Queen
c4 check right and right for and now I'm
cut this should beef fights yeah and who
do we like I think we do we like what no
no no commentators curse I just called
it now we're gonna ask for some lunch
money - yeah big early there Wow it's
cursed
oh yeah yeah he walked himself right
into it
and Royal Forks are the best oil Forks
are the best we've had that we've had
enough of those to be happy today where
does that put us in terms of the
standings if we deed hop over here and
right now Sergio has five and a half out
of six I miss I misspoke
I thought MBL had a full point lead that
was wrong now well I guess you were
right at the time but the other games
Thank You Sergei Grigoryants gets a
victory and and that means we're we're
kind of seeing a clear leader set right
look at those four guys right there at
the top and and so that puts us in
pretty clear understanding of who's
who's pulling away with it right now of
the games remaining we see a grandmaster
we saw lose earlier to a very nice Queen
sacked in BL we've got our boy Lawrence
Trent let's maybe we'll open up that one
right here and see see what miss Trent
is doing
whoever's black Naaman taters curse I've
had this happen one time before during a
title Tuesday yester where there were
about five games and every time I
clicked on the game or somebody clicked
on the next one is somebody lost and so
maybe they're better there I'm the
uppercut knockout yes oh you're you're
oh York Meyers game is finished sorry
your alkene games here we go
two in a row I bring up the gable a
weave keep it going see you why not
you're under heavens here I'll just I'm
not I don't know what the positions are
so I just randomly click on a game okay
so this one will be a few moves won't be
an instant resignation but no it's a win
King D fine
no I meant J as far as what they reside
within within three seconds he didn't
have to resign which is amazing right
let's keep this going who knows what's
gonna happen here wow I'm just clicking
on the next one she's eleven so usually
it's within three to five seconds so
right now we don't have that all right
you can resign I could resign but uh
alright seconds to do it
Wow now there we go they just they know
that they're being watched apparently
and now they're embarrassed and so they
throw in the towel and this other one we
can we just confidently resign another
one or they'll be made so he went in
order but did you know what's funny is
again I could have randomly clicked on
this one earlier and not the other one
if I would have missed all those mates I
know it seems weird but it's happened
before we're like in order of how we
click the game's end so just funny all
right here we go
Sergei Grigoryants can anybody stop
Maxime vache Lavrov that might be the
question we have here as he sort of
answers the question who's the favorite
in the event apparently apparently MVL
is right now some no question about it
but that was pretty what are you poison
or something right because I could have
quit believing this one but it happens
it's just very funny Wow
okay d4r very normal there we go useful
opening we're gonna get a Kings Indian
here watch we're gonna get a g6 of
Bishop g7 and a wrecker of code just
like that we've got a Kings Indian over
here yeah this could be our most well
okay I was about to say our most
normal-looking opening of all time and
suddenly I came a what a B 5 C 5 yeah
this is a that's no that wasn't strange
to say the least it's so let's talk
about that yeah we've got we're putting
the world's strongest chess players like
a even if they're not all number one
right we've got some of the world's
strongest chess players but because
chess is such a game of pattern
recognition you put them in a position
they've never seen before and sometimes
they make those moves that even as we
hear you just say right a weird
positional concession C 5 and you're
like right so what is that about chess
and pattern recognition that maybe
people can learn about here because
that's something that even strong
players make sometimes dubious
positional decisions when they're faced
with a structure they've never seen
before
yeah boy I can't I I hesitate to look
too deeply into that one just because
well I mean it's a it
the ticking clock right DB the earliness
factor but that definitely seemed like a
massive hiccup there that just occurred
and by the way
nothing's wrong with the move Knight c7
you want to go 97 95 and you know make a
plant but there was even something more
to be suggested about d6 and just like
right away look that yeah this is this
King in the center right okay he did get
he got around to playing d6 right away
thereafter so no harm no foul looks very
good I like blacks position I love this
Knight coming to d5 that's a monster
square yeah you've got a you've got the
white majority yeah if I could magically
get e4 then we'd be okay with White's
whole approach even with c5 but it's
gonna be hard for white to to force that
through although I guess I guess with
the open C file here now black has to be
careful you can never play d5 just
really cement your control over the
e-file without permanently weakening
this c6 pawn here so that's a little
right but okay first of all it was it
was funny I mentally I had always you
know considered that the bishop on h8
was unopened hilarious but again I do
see white white on the backfoot here
that black has some very very nice
control over the position I don't
understand the move a for it all like at
all yeah I I thought that black
intention was to play b4 to kill the
bishop on d2 you know yeah
keep that plate I agree that looks super
strong actually and it's that was really
what you know like no yeah we let that
back yeah and we have that problem we're
black black likes the Queen side
majority black likes the open e file
pressure but you know you if you haven't
gotten anything concrete you've also got
this potentially weak pawn on c6
and white does have two Center pawns
which according to Aaron nimzowitsch are
better than one I don't know I mean it's
not it's not so clear anymore for MVL
although okay I still think black is a
little better I I prefer black as well
but I do feel at least I have the
impression it a lot of his advantages
have been squandered over the last say
six seven moves 94 okay
there was some issue potentially with
Knight no I don't think so Knight G
thinking about something like Knight g5
and somehow trying to Queen f5 and
Knight f3 and getting okay but from
White's point of view it's it's time to
actually contest fight for that e4
square f3 Knight g5 unfortunately
there's a double threat of Queen h3
check and rookie 3 so I just have to
prepare f3 and maybe I start with
something like h4 I like h4 a lot I
think I'd be able to time there because
he really wanted to make sure he chose
the right plan f5 right a really
communal idea he's saying I'm gonna make
sure you don't get these light scores
back even at the risk of opening my king
that's right yeah so that'll be because
now you have d3 that you're eyeing and
that could expose the move that you
questions with a four so this has been
this is a tough battle more than we've
seen the last couple of games the MBL
faced by the way sergio mm had to him I
die I'm not familiar with him but he's
he's putting up a hell of a lot better
resistance MBL's earlier victories in
you now know it's it's it's it's a
full-scale fight yeah we've gotten the
weaknesses of c6 versus III right which
one will be he's your target I like this
move g5 it wasn't obvious until he
actually put it on the board but there
was a moment there that white could have
been considering h4 Knight f4 and
planning the night on f/4g fight just
stripped that idea away and introduced
g4 9 up - good move who is this masked
man
yeah yeah I mean impressed he's uh yeah
and he's it he plays regularly in our
title Tuesday's he's been one of the
stronger Russian grandmasters who's been
competing on chess calm this year
because I didn't know who he was until
he qualified for the speed chess
championship as well so full disclosure
yeah hey well wants g4 right and then
and then get the idea
yeah he's been fighting for some time on
these light squares on the Kings side
now Bishop d2 okay yeah I can understand
that he was concerned about ninety five
in tempo against the e3 pawn but that
really doesn't stop black from
initiating g4 I thought white was gonna
have to play h3 yeah that's my thought
the same just to slow black down maybe
maybe white is isn't things heating up
here Danny yeah no and look at the time
and this is even as the games have been
really right both sides have potential
King problems both sides have potential
positional weaknesses and I think that
that puts us in a fun time pressure
situation because maybe we'll get up
maybe we'll get an exciting blunder and
we'll for sure I I think it's definitely
on the agenda so I see Queen e6 Queen d5
as blacks ideas I think you're gonna
have to pitch the epon and just play
rook h1 he didn't play everything I
wonder if in this position white had a
shot like d5 followed by swinging the
Queen but that's I don't know too late
now but interesting oh now he goes for
d5 though that the clearance sacrifice
right opening the diagonal and the Queen
I think that that's uh that couldn't
have possibly a lot of pressure
well Queen d4 runs into rook c4 c4 Queen
has to drop back to D bow we drop back
to but he really does basically right is
that coming back here comes d4 and I'm
gonna grab the diagonal first yeah we
should have play d4 first but
well I saw Queen c6 with the idea of d4
Shack but but I'm also walking into rook
takes h6 now that was another reason to
play d4 44 check Oh
Intermezzo you have d4 check oh yeah
yeah and I think d4 and rook c2 is
definitely definitely our blacks agenda
yeah what was the idea
oh I forgot that efore guards this rook
it's a blunder no it's not clear yet I
take on e4 f5 takes e4 okay with the
threat of III check right devastate my
self apiece but there's a ton of
problems here for white yeah eat okay so
maybe you're right maybe it's still
still better I'm sure when he calculated
this MBL had the same yes a blind spot
yeah Wow and I mean talk about random
universe things okay but he's thinking
about it because he's got he's got
another shot maybe Knight e4 is even
stronger than F even Fe okay he goes for
it yeah he's calculations I did you know
because I guess if Knight takes you take
with check and then rook c2 is oh is he
just why is rook c2 not winning the
Queen guards b7 against this Queen the
Queen guard right for against the Queen
after example kim jiwon look c2 Queen
before okay so he's still okay it just I
thought I thought maybe this is gonna be
yeah yeah yeah no I follow yeah I mean I
suspected it's completely winning for
black but I just didn't quite see the
knockout do we have the position on the
board that we yeah team G one has been
played okay so here's the moment of
truth
as they say yeah time on it's got less
than less than 20 seconds remaining and
well what is that he's threatening g3 so
I guess he's just no no we should o b7
is definitely protected that's very but
Bishop f4
now I thought he was gonna start with
rook C - yeah and then go for this you
know Queen a - switching over lemon
giving up the G cyclone would check that
is a fact that was a bit risky a very
wise decision but I think a wise
decision I did I think it's time to just
say okay I've got a play for an attack
because okay I don't want to Wow he
bailed out okay Wow
well thankfully had something for
everybody yeah I go back to the position
where he played Knight takes e4 because
I didn't see how White was gonna handle
f5 takes e4 the far more promising and
alluring
has it between g1 and III can't be
played because of the pin on f6 oh no I
think that that must have been in right
so brilliant I love it
what's fascinating about the radius was
this was two clearance sacrifices
back-to-back and maybe if Maxine had
them the same idea but played d4
first-ever I've been a different story
right but but having that same sort of
blind spot that we did hey but by the
way that means that when you do play d4
there is a threat of this ship takes h6
ah so yeah yeah so cuz so it's Queen c6
check no it must be winning it must be
it was like it has to be winning for
black yeah you're right two is gonna run
into bishop takes with check but maybe
you could even just take back there
because the Queen's hanging oh that was
a great game oh my maybe maybe a game
that despite it ending peacefully in a
draw looking at our standings but we'll
come back as one of the biggest games
for nvl2 to win this term and if he goes
on to do so cuz he he believed it was
winning he blundered right holds on at
six and five out of seven yes and a game
that reminds me to mention our our David
a lot of thinkers book because we're
giving away this book to our three
favorite games today let us know in the
chat what you think your favorite games
are me and yaz will have final say maybe
I'll give you as final say but right now
and the
seems to be involved in two of our royal
faves exactly well MDL for sure with
that Queen sacrifice and by the way look
at Bartos he's in the number third
position he's got six out of seven I
mean he only lost two MVL I mean that
was his one less and he's got six wins
so I know that was a battle in the last
game they don't give me time because the
next round is underway check it out
Sala saloon versus mvl yeah and okay
look bishops is your favorite they're
doing this for yes right your favorite
g4 okay so the problem when you've got
these bishops in these positions is you
need to play something like g4 and f4 to
give them open diagonals or g3 a g4 and
h4 again to and immediately I've seen
these two moves you ladies start a game
and lose and check the moves to
checkmate right these are this is how
you lose to the fools mate exactly I
really don't like MBL's approach to that
his opening here really it's bad in my
view yeah they would name I mean hey
look you know he's a great great great
player but within you know four moves
yeah the King position yeah the critical
future squares of the center seem to
belong to black because black guards
this d5 square and there's already
immediate access to all of these dark
squares I I agree with you a same thing
MBL is obviously great and has been the
favorite today but this looks like a bad
way to start the position is white
exactly exactly
now okay Bishop e5 that was a a peculiar
move i I don't know exactly but and if
it provokes a reaction like rook F to
well then I gotta say it was good
cuz rook f2 looks ugly that's what is g5
he wants 9f
six I'm guessing in me but these guys
are like wasting Tempe right g5 is just
oh no g5 you know it was it was it was
what a pity I hate a knight f6 the panic
it was disco the panic at chess960 they
look at a piece that's not active and
they want to free it and they're not
they're not developing or getting pieces
into the center here so this is becoming
a weird setup maybe maybe white can play
Queen d3 or Queen e2 here and get
castled long and suddenly it becomes
something that looks much more playable
for what exactly
no I mean either one of those Queen f3
also just you know get your King out of
Dodge and into safety
yeah and white will be a very happy
camper
oh my but that was some very very
strange opening decisions by both
players that g5 wasting a tempo like
that what was he thinking weird and it
leaves this e7 pollen permanently
crippled it's a very strange structure
now for black yes this Bishop looks
happy now but if you play king b1 and if
I can understand that but I agree with
you
ya know king b1 is that that's an
automatic you want to get off that
diagonal and there's even you start to
think about undermining ideas like h4 92
engine h4 92 ideas Bishop kind of trick
saves that rather than just getting
castle I mean you can't save the bishop
here and you work anymore
sorry anyway because there's a nice bit
more coming I'd right that's a
surprising move by Maxime I think he
knew thank you for me too it was better
yeah I think you can be one was like an
automatic I just even if I wanted to
play the move Bishop d3 my hand in the
game of blitz who would have taken over
a kind of a dr. Strangelove type of
situation yeah okay King b1 I mean again
you got a dist yeah he doesn't know now
he saved the bishop pair which is a keep
and now by the way black should have
played
ceefor instead of cows along but okay -
very nice ideas for white knight G 292
the bishop on f4 currently trapped you
could capture that bishop and on a good
day get to play Bishop G 1 to H 2 yeah
well I promise you a pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow I say that is a
tunnel
I would like to drive down right there
the the other idea I was going to say is
is d5 coming at some point yeah okay I
think your idea really is the more more
principle than kind of best way to take
advantage of blacks no no no no d5 and
Bishop takes a7 those types of tactics
those are very very very good tactic
standing I like the only reason I'd
hesitate to d5 because the knight on D
second is crap right you don't want to
do it that's probably why he dismisses
it right you just don't want to brush or
even breathe life into them exactly and
I mean when when your opponent is
suffering you throw in the handle
actually I think the line is when your
opponent is drowning yeah you know you
don't want to give him any reason you
know that he's still in you know is you
should be fighting anymore Knight eat
Knight G - pardon me very nice move
Sallah in trouble at this very crucial
round juncture in the in the tournament
yeah yes he's it's nice yeah it's is it
nine or ten rounds it's nine it's now
you tell me we only have not anymore
that's what I'm saying this is this
cookie for the trip to Reykjavik yep
these are our two of our leaders
everybody if you're just joining us
again this is the chess calm 960 Chester
championship the first with me as
Grandmaster yes or Sarah won we're
having a ball we got a lot of viewers
over 2500 of them on Twitch and no no
homepage love from twitch today which
means where these are all organic
viewers who just came to watching you
lovely well thank you so much for it to
each and every one a shadow
first of all once again it's a pleasure
for me this is my first with Dani g5
automatic by the black the f5 square is
a great square for blacks pieces don't
you let them set up as a set of roost on
this g5 f I square let what black have a
pawn instead and now Bishop h2 and
Bishop takes f4 easy easy idea play okay
h4 I thought Bishop h2 but I like this
too
when night g6 will run into h5 yeah
trying to go after the e6 Bishop there's
you know maybe quickly grab your file
here rookie water rookie - followed by
Bishop h2 I'm I'm loving white on a lot
of levels
I like 92 that's to stick the knight on
f4 kind of thing I think your idea no D
5 D Phi yeah this is brilliant but it is
brilliant
we didn't lie should check okay he's got
Bishop takes f5 coming in the end and
now you don't you now you go Knight d5
and now you go rookie - and you all the
pieces are perfectly harmonized white is
got hitting a7 he's gonna like Queen
takes f4 mate and rookie - yeah I love
it that is that is every unit flows
together right it's like it was planned
Symphony fate look at that yeah one of
my very favorite players who really
doesn't get the love he deserved was the
seal Smee sloth yeah and if you look at
his games people you are going to be
amazed at his harmonic convergence I
mean yeah he did some beautiful things
and this is a beautiful convergence that
MBL is putting together there
very very impressive game hasn't won it
yeah I could see that see a heart
horrifying blunder you know of almost a
minute - he's he's again showing why
stronger players usually when they're
winning they're also up on time so he's
I don't expect him to blow this one at
this one no and especially when you see
that I mean as rum and Gigi hush really
famously declared White has pawn and
compensations right Bishop h2 rook takes
h7 be greedy if you like why not G for
Queen e5 is the automatic I won't look
for ways to bring into m5 Queen g4
looked also really really good because
you just love to have you put and take
the knight just take the night you know
the ghost of phantom and Banquo says I
wish I got as excited about anything as
yes or Sarah one gets about good piece
coordination so yeah exists it just
brings a smile to your face you know
like when and especially and I love this
predicting when you when you see that
these top grandmasters you found the
same idea that they play I mean decide
wow well you and it's nice when like you
say cuz it happens all at once where the
pieces don't seem to be doing something
super aggressive or effective but then
it's that one breakthrough move and you
and then you recognize that all these
pieces sort of have a long-distance
relationship on the squares on a seven
on d6 on c7 I mean it just comes to life
and it's it is a beautiful it's magic
yeah this was a this was a very very
impressive game and in addition to that
crazy and wild draw last round against
Sergei Grigoryants this is this is maybe
gonna put Maxine in the in the position
to win the event with that grandmaster
Salim goes down we pop back over how
standings we see yes the OB happy
leapfrogged sir
brands who also won okay but he's now
got seven and a half out of eight with
one last round to go he can't play
Grigoryants or the man in fourth place
they're bought Bart Bart oh uh excuse me
I'm sorry I'm on Bartos soko Saco
because he is won against him and he's
already won against Grandmaster Celine
so uh yeah we could see your money your
mire yeah we could see an international
master the Jerry or Terry Renato we've
seen him play play a lot and he's done
well in some chess960 entitled Tuesday
tournament so he's a very talented
international master especially a blitz
mm-hmm okay who do we have by the way in
our in books that David is giving uh
I've got I've got MVL for all three we
just give all the books to Maxine I
don't know that David would be happy
about that it's been pretty impressive
and maybe the fans can help us out in
the chat or some of my teammates what do
we got here I just clicked you a game
and we have two bishops open position
the ships are better than one and to
meet you Andre can surprise that Black
has even still making nobody didn't like
jinxed him as soon as I click on the
game it ends within a few demands
yeah the curse continues here I think
that white would also just resign as
black will sacrifice and win with the
h-bond so frustrating to be white chess
is eternal but so is this loss a loss is
for keeps
yes sir yes you know what they say right
never goes away it's true and you know
I've I've traveled the world and I
always enjoy it when I run into somebody
and they go yes sir why why you know
you've done so well and they did it to
that and they go you know I only beat
you that one time
and I'm like number one who is this
person
where when did we play yes you had come
to my chess club and you did a sign mole
at the school remember their wins and
here we have it Danny
last last round Andre Divya
deviance DB DB s not a deviant but a CV
it can be probably divvy out canactually
at knowing the the idea in the Russian
language and diet so we have the Andre
TV Otakon versus Leo B's you know yeah
okay so V 45 and we see right away that
Bishop g2 e4 ideas are on White's agenda
and also depending it's more like one of
those tempo things and black tries to
mimic white black has to be worried that
the bishop might come to f4 to e5 it's
fine how you don't like you know pinned
the knight on f6 to the Queen on AJ
that's kind of a funny thing Bishop f4
we should be fine I'm not sure what the
probability is on that but how many
rounds have we seen the Queen's start in
the corner today yes I mean it's it's
very high right yeah yeah very high and
surprising for me and we all didn't
start with one g4s because he's been
successful right at this maybe maybe
that game masala he realized that maybe
he had gone too far uh-huh well here he
already saved white
yeah white is doing nicely seems to be
pressing he has options to castle short
I'm seeing castles short c2 c4 ideas of
Bishop takes beset not gonna go quietly
into the night yeah
but now at 6:00 we'll win the two
bishops after Eva yeah yeah II for white
will have a favorable what
okay so black decides to prevent that
he's gonna take with the pawn so that he
can meet Eve for with this but but now
he's made a huge positional concession
with these double pawns for sure he has
and this is one of those the cure may be
worse than the disease
whatever they say any Nina Jones he
chose poorly
so I yes exactly shows well yeah but it
should takes d 6e for c6 and okay white
has some but black has two bishops here
I just don't know what black has and I'm
seeing ideas Queen before a foreigner
over okay f5 makes sense to slow down
any ideas of efore but I'm still seeing
Queen before c4
I'm seeing a for rook a3 Queen b4 and c4
kind of ideas where is blacks King doing
that's a great point especially because
white in the plane you gave the Queen
before in a foreign all these things
like in Castle short at almost any any
moment moment and blacks not castling
short anymore Ryan he's probably not
castling long for one the good moe the
good news about this move rook c8 is
Queen before now gets handsomely met by
rook c4 so maybe a for I was gonna say
maybe a for first and he played it yet -
uh exactly so that the move Queen before
it can come rook c4 Queen b3 now
possible due to the fact that you write
for doesn't work so yeah that's that's a
nice move there by Maxine yeah well I
must say his play one other thing I mean
Maggie what can you say about Magnus I
mean he's the world champion the guy's
just too damn good was his consistency
yeah he's consistent so far I mean MVL
pretty impressive right well you don't
even wait amazing the event with eight
and a half out of nine right and when
you're always a game where you know
you could have gone either way by the
end but he also had chances to win so
know he consistency has been MBL's
calling card today I agree he's yeah
very smooth operator right now yeah
sunday sunny Saturday loves you a smooth
operator yeah yeah no you're right you
yeah h5 is may be preparing for blackie
saying if you castles short maybe I'll
have some sort of chance but what about
a move like h3 I guess you don't want H
for okay you don't want to yeah I was
thinking that he was definitely gonna go
Queen d2 and Castle short but he decided
with the move king b2 that
well his Kings actually quite safe on
the Kings at love King b8 blacks back in
the game yeah like she's banging
actually think unless you're getting in
c4 and an attack against b7 then black
isn't not that yeah though those double
pawns in the center control ranger
squares they're looking a lot better
than they first it plus you always have
that long-term feature of the bishop
pair which even if it's not noticing
right away right everybody at some point
the position maybe we'll get that open
tension that makes that dark square
bishop extremely valuable so you always
have to be careful with the potential
there right and this is actually a
demonstration that something's not
altogether copacetic about White's
position that he's gonna have to play so
slow play his c3 c4 great he's gonna
have to play king b2 Knight B to King a
292 c4 to get it in and and did I lose
yes yes you there yes are you there yes
I am okay sorry get lost lost you just
for a sec so complete that thought you
said King a 292 c4 yeah and that's how
he's gonna get in c4 but it did it it
doesn't come with that triumphal Eve
yeah and what do Queen h7 just setting
up a nasty potential for fi before
and don't yell is patiently playing he
had to defend the night to kind of
prevent the power of that just skull
attack no but you're right this has
become anybody's game here the tension
is all about who wants to break who
wants to break more but if you do it
don't give your opponent more life than
they currently have right you don't want
to open up the patient too fast
that's right okay what do you think
about the risky king a3 a followed by c4
Wow I think I think you said a little
risky but because you're always walking
into that discover Schekman maybe maybe
you can get away with that night before
I think it's preparing for the tactical
dynamics that will occur after c4 right
he's putting the night and please yep
kind of pointing at the same area and
and hoping that c4 will be a little
trickier to handle them look at time by
the way
time is where MBL is is it really in the
lead in this game right now
mm-hmm and once again great clock
management what else can you call it
yeah whoo a5 on a target square but
what's he saying with that didn't expect
that one I really didn't expect that one
now we have to reset our minds and start
saying okay you're no longer playing for
c4 when you play 85 is he playing for f4
and switching rich fine yeah and the
reason oh wow
give you out Wow get not gonna sit tight
he's gonna try to make something happen
bad whoa I was gonna say bad idea -
right back to d3 and keep that pawn on
f4 in your pocket yeah but MBL went for
this and not only slightly worse I think
that pawn on e5 really doesn't belong
there
yeah I'm surprised by this because it's
private d yeah efore might just come
with the needed right oh the tempo that
it needs in a place that needs each
defies the Knights position by
increasing the pressure to d5 just in
time right boy talk about just in time
yeah if it was NC 4 he's gonna be able
to flip the script ooh the e-file and
all the sudden right black would love to
just focus in on this overextended the
the calf that's wandered too far from
the herd but I was like he's coming
and is he better kidding no it's
probably still a draw rook up but wait a
minute no he's much better I apologized
both deep both deep pawns are falling no
then it's just one okay the reason the
rook comes behind the park very
important in your component games get
your books behind the pawns d5 c4 c5
let's go very interesting he decides to
close off the King's entry before
pushing really really accurate actually
there now and now black is is being
strangled yes yes uh funnily enough he
actually didn't need to move before he
could have just gone live and he should
have right because B fire I mean it made
it a lot of you know you're right that
was uh he should have just won he's got
full steam ahead but this is good enough
king d4 and no stopping skills yes the
rush of the pawns almost like the rock
ending I had yesterday when you and I
were prepping for the call right
although not quite it's not quite as
pretty well again we're seeing this very
impressive technique from MDL it seems
like when the position becomes critical
that's when he really starts putting
together a whole sequence of really
really just great moves yeah powerful
chess King d5 he's gonna shine Queen
he's gonna win the rook and win it yep
and then he made but when the King and
pawn ending and we're gonna have our
first-ever
chest comm 960 champion right we we bow
to salute festively only obese Maxime
Vashti the grog takes the cake bye
my only a super superhero give gays in
there to bring it to a close with eight
and a half out of 90 goog Orient's won
again we didn't get a chance to see his
last two games but talk about a strong
performance there right yes he finished
the question thousand with eight and a
half out and I saw eight out of nine Wow
Andre Caen I'm drinking not far behind
his member on drinking so Lawson was
that rough game - Matt - MBL yes oh I
see he must have also dropped a couple
drawers but the the big loss was Tim vo
that's right Wow okay still going on
yeah let's take your hey finally a game
at night of players gonna resign on the
bear the curse is broken the car yes
finally but I gotta tell you this looks
like a dream position for black yeah
this is International Master out playing
a very strong Grandmaster right now
impressive wow that this is what we call
light square control yeah let's say that
is a beautiful night aron nimzowitsch is
rolling over in his grave about this
bishop on f2 this is a yes although we
are you have a good mind system
discussion to have right my system but a
very overrated book yes super old it was
very strange when I was growing up
everybody was saying you know my system
I've got to read it really really great
stuff and I just found it asinine I mean
I just totally totally totally
ridiculous nimzowitsch for me was just
an author that I mean more if he was
more into it there like his he wanted to
invent words and invent philosophy right
more than he did about knows yeah you
know it's funny cuz I had the same I
have a similar experience different
generation of course but a similar
spirit and I was sort of told and forced
to read it and I didn't really know that
I had the right to say I don't know that
I like this book but as when I heard you
go on that rant I forget what it was it
at the Sinquefield Cup coverage about
yeah I think it was why I was like I was
like I agree I was like like my system
is first of all it's not a very
enjoyable
it's a weird blow book right anyway
funds right yeah and and this idea of
overprotection right um me one guy
entire employment who's won a game
because of overprotection I was like
okay blockade fine restraint blockade
destroy got it they're very very nice
and nimzowitsch wasn't the first guy who
ever did that yeah but I mean
overprotection
the immortal overprotection game my god
I mean it was just it it was it was
laughable atrocious and yet some people
that I really do respect and they say
nimzowitsch was good one of the people
who like names of it was Robert burned
my master carpet burn and I couldn't
believe it
by the way gurgi is fighting back yeah
he work any better he's gonna maybe play
Brooksie - okay he was worried about
Queen g7 check I guess so he decided to
trade into the Brooke ending yes so rook
g6 King c3 King looks just like a draw
sorry one at one exciting note is that
as this final game comes to a close here
we will be joined momentarily by the
winner of the first chess960
championship don't go anywhere
MBL is chatting with me on skype right
now he's actually ready to join us yeah
as you ready to be joined but yes
here we go an opener then actually go
ahead and stop sharing my screen yeah so
we can just talk okay here hi Maxie I'm
trying to get things right here so we
can have a nice a nice irony yes sir
hello max in congratulations
thanks yes very impressive yeah I don't
really know what to expect like I have
an SD card so I wasn't sure my head
would function but
it's happened it did Morris yeah I just
blended couple of things Thank You c'n
squig audience is evil
yes yeah II for the bishop yeah it was
great thank you for right away of course
we were we were also we were literally
all Sympatico on that one the universe
had us aligned because we were saying
the same thing we suggested D for first
you didn't play it and we were like oh
it's okay but then all of a sudden we
realized the bishop was guarding the
brook and that like had some problems so
yeah well congratulations actually it
was actually pretty funny but yes of
course congratulations now you wanna
you've won a trip to record it how
exciting yeah it's nice I mean I I've
been to work I make it's a nice place I
don't think I would go but well we were
just gonna ask will recommend a surprise
I recommend it but yeah I don't think
I'll be able to to attend them in like
this it's one trip to too many what what
are your plans for this year well you
and I you know we talked a lot last year
that you were I think you probably
played more games of any Grandmaster in
the top ten you were at every Grand Prix
and every World Cup and every grand
chest or event I mean you were all over
the place so what are your plans for
2018 if now that you've you've started
2018 the right way by winning the first
chess calm 960 championship but are you
gonna take it a little more easy this
year not as many tournaments oh and I
mean I would have said my main pain is a
candidates but I didn't qualify but of
course as a Grantchester
and what I mean everything's still
coming into place but I should have in
enough tournaments you know not to feel
like I should retire don't retire though
though you're very exciting player to
watch but will you attend the candidates
in any capacity Maxie
well I don't think I will physically
attend it I mean like going to Berlin
you know it's not far away but Sonia am
i tough Ganzer bocek's might be a bit
hard for my you know your my feelings
but of course I will be following I mean
yes it's one event you know it just and
you just cannot miss even if it would
have preferred you know to play it
instead of watching it at home well
despite see you know obviously the huge
disappointment that that you weren't
able to get in and not trying to belabor
or talk too much about that point and
remind you of it a lot of chess fans
cried tears when you were not able to
together the system but maybe I haven't
talked to you since then what are your
thoughts on that I mean is it something
that you feel could be could be
redressed as far as how the system is
set up and given that you had such a
phenomenal 2017 and we're certainly in a
position as one of the best players in
the world that we think you should be
there so what are your thoughts on how
how all that broke down
maxime yes are you here I'm with you I
had gotten a little interruption cut off
but I heard the last part of your
question but I think Mac I think we lost
Maxine I think we did too
I the tournament is officially over fans
so if you're just joining us you see the
you see the prize is given right there
maxi bhashya the Grob takes first Sergey
Grigoryants in second and to meet you on
Drake and in 3rd Mac Senor Mac no
question and that was like answering it
and the call you were inside the
controversial question of the Illuminati
killed the call yeah something like that
and anyway so I'll answer it again so
the question was about the candidates
right answers yes indeed a system
I mean just always going to be deserving
players is going to miss out whatever
the system is because like I mean all
the players who plays are deserving and
there's you know a few more players that
could they would have attended I'm sick
about vision I'm thinking about Chicago
of course I'm thinking about myself
so like I don't see any dramatic change
to do to the system because I think I've
already know it values you know your
skills and you know just because I
didn't qualify it means that the system
is trash you know but I would get to it
you know if it was in my power I would
get rid of the one card of course that's
what is the only thing I will I could
address and then okay you whatever the
system is pretty fair so I'm alright
with it
maximum question for you when you look
at Berlin and the current candidates who
would you think is Magnus's biggest
challenger opponent who could be who
could give him a great match and it's
hard to say because you know of course
it's clear I mean to me I might -
himself might correct me but I think
starting from actually is is much with
Sergei and then most fish what 2017 yet
he had a few very nice events I'm
thinking about sinker Cup in terms of
level of play I'm thinking about tide of
mess but overall he hasn't been playing
in classical tournaments as well as as
is usual stand ups right so you know I
mean first of all if if he doesn't I
mean if you still keeps this trend and
doesn't show it's best just you know
pretty much everyone can give him a very
tough fight
I mean I mean one thing that could give
to his credit is that even if he's not
having a good yo stay number one in the
world so that's not relaxing
but yeah anyway I think the gap is I
mean has been decreasing of ebbs so you
know that means that you know everyone
could give him a challenge I mean as
answers the question of styles of course
but it's you know people adapt when they
play in a match so yes it's not to say
you know I mean at some point you know
and nobody would have expected for
instance that I think a bit Cap'n Branca
I think of the time so clear or for that
matter Sergei to play Magnus to overtime
right exactly
yeah well maybe Danny somebody on the
chat might have a question for Maxime
otherwise we let him go and that's
aggression let's uh let's let's do that
let me load up let me load up twitch or
chess talk on TV and and see if we can
see if we can bring bring a great
question to the forefront from the
audience yeah so Maxine this is you just
won the first chess comm 960
championship we were wondering
beforehand how many of the top players
in the world feel good about their
chess960 skills right there there used
to be the amber of them honestly I
didn't feel good before the tournament
but maybe I reconsider
I mean I felt like mmm but maybe because
this time I was a bit more focused I
don't know but in general I I have a
tendency to blender sink I invite to my
tournament so I could have taken a
pretty mean different direction
if not I mean in this game against Gabby
Reece abyss you know I mean I think I
was in certain trouble inside games so
yeah in the end I won it you know I
turned the tables but other
of course it would have been a much
different story yeah
I must say I thought that your play was
very very consistent also your clock
management was well excellent you
weren't getting into trouble and you
were making decisions very quickly III
thought it was very impressive I didn't
know dude did you do any training laughs
it was just 96 960 tournament beforehand
no I didn't actually I mean of course
you know I was like you know trying to
get my bishops rank in general and but
she knows that this much everyone can
figure out for yourself but yeah I was
looking for positions that you know
we're a bit different than regular chess
because afterwards that's actually the
reason why people play chess 960 right
exactly
enjoy we were wondering that because we
we talked about the balance there's a
lot of good questions are coming in
right now just so all the chatters know
I'm watching both switches yes TV unit
no I mean to be firm in probably my best
game was against demand raking what I
was gonna say is we were talking with
the balance of chess960 where you look
at the the initial piece configuration
and you make a decision am I am I trying
to fix this broken setup to go for the
center to get my king safe to do
classical chess principles or am I just
playing with them in the way that
they're set up and and seeing if I can
make this work right and so some of the
games it's like you're starting with g4
and Queen coming to h3 and then other
games you know it's it's almost like a
battle of who can Reema nuber first to
grab control over the critic critical
areas of the thought I was trying to mix
things up I mean that's you know if
you're not having fun on your paint
chess960 you just write you got a it's
time to retire yeah actually I just
wanted to say to Abby oh that
congratulations we were giving out three
book prizes and they're very handsome
books by the way one to yourself for
your victory over and Dracon we just
thought that was real masterclass that
was I think that was your best game of
the turn
what do you think yeah I also think so
like I like it very much I mean even my
first three moves like g5 takes e4
Knight f6 it you know it just getting
the game in the right direction I
thought right and then I managed to get
you know making because at first my plan
was actually to Castle kingside right
now which we expected yeah but then I
realized I might as well go up the
center with my books and then I yeah I
managed to get my pieces out and his is
on Quinn site was not getting developed
any attention to that costume begin the
end yeah well very very very nice but so
you will be getting this special book
Danny will tell you all about it that's
right that's right you've probably seen
it david Lauda's book the thinker's and
will will come up I'm sure there'll be a
picture of you in there actually I don't
think but yeah you look a little relaxed
you look a little too relaxed when
you're when you're playing chess that's
probably what no we we have so many
questions that came in I'm not gonna
keep your you here all day there's a lot
of comments from both the chesty be chat
and twitch a lot of people just wish you
congratulations Robert o 585 we've got
one question is who is who's your who's
your best friend amongst the world's
elite players of all the other players
you you guys all rub elbows with all the
time people want to know who is the most
social and who do you hang out with the
most of any of them if you had to say
well I actually uncut with with a few of
them I don't want to to pick besties but
I ain't got quite a lot in general with
with Lebanon Fabiano area for that
matter okay you're you're starting a
streaming channel one fan one fan is
obviously I talked about that one that
we're playing well today once you get
going how often do you think you'll be
able to play your games on chess calm as
you as you crush people's souls and
three check yeah actually you know my
plan was of course to get a bit
of of training as well I mean useful
training before tournaments you know I
might as well give a few of my subsets
you know I thought that could be fun but
of course I looking for what to play
king of King Kamsa hail sweet cheques of
course and stuff like that make this
dream a in French so of course
there's I have many plans I don't have
enough time four of them and yeah I mean
I don't think I'll be a regular streamer
like you know twice a week that would be
them too much but lucky if I met her my
practice to streamer at least once a
week maybe more I don't know nice well
there's a lot of questions similar to
things that almost every child
Grandmaster with about the performance
of alpha zero so I'm not gonna kill you
with that I'm actually gonna tell all
the fans in the chat chess TV or twitch
if you want to see Maxime and a lot of
other top players who gave their
opinions when alpha zero came along you
can actually check out our our news
videos Peter doctors got a chance to
catch up with so many and and get
opinions on the the machine learning the
self-taught supercomputer a lot of
questions were how would alpha zero do
in chess960 so anyway just no need to
worry about that but that was that was a
tough you would do pretty well thank you
thank you chess bay 94 for gifting that
last sub to Kappa blanket chest BAE it
hurts feels bad you said you're only
here to see yasser not me and max seems
so i don't know oh sorry everyone loves
you yes max see we will teach you we
will keep you any longer you're awesome
thanks for joining us there the fans
love you and next time the candidates
rolls around we we will we'll all be as
excited as you are to be there so we'll
be with you in spirit so okay thank you
for joining us Maxime and now we will
will will talk soon I hope yeah sure
okay thank you like thank you for
joining us mixing bye bye bye bye nice
that was a nice bonus
from the winner so thank you to MBL for
joining us yeah well thank you for
flying alongside me as you are no
aspirin as the fans said they're here to
see you are you are this was really
enjoyable I personally had had a great
time and especially if you're being
exhausted from yesterday full disclosure
I've always admit that I'm maybe
sometimes I'm a little tired of it but
the today's show was full of energy and
I give all the credit to you you were
awesome and this was a lot of fun well
you're just coming off back-to-back
great great shows I mean wow naca versus
Sergei was by meeting Maggie I mean
that's just like the ghost guys to my
minor the two greatest and by the way
I'll even throw in nvl2 he's an
incredible blitz player but what Maggie
storm yesterday was amazing so what to
say he's just hats off and today and MBL
was in man god he was a monstrous form
yeah again I'll have to reread play
through his games but I didn't see too
many blunders in this play Wow thank you
you're right consistency you made the
comparison to Magnus and as we talked
about I think affair even before you and
I went live about when Magnus did
blunder it was so small it was like a
pawn that then he didn't were even
regret giving up it was very strange
especially and and I don't remember I
mean we were making these slight
criticisms at times like if they were
playing against principle chest not the
center but over I mean overall max seems
play was seem to always be with the
doctor ordered I mean he just he really
he really was impressive today
so exactly exactly all around and again
a really big shout out to our twitch and
just become members for joining us and
making it fun and watching and if it's
not for you guys we wouldn't be doing
this yep thank you yes sir we look
forward to having you on future events
thanks to everybody for tuning in we are
gonna sign off right now and hopefully
we'll have yessir back sooner rather
than later and peace out everybody peace
out